bien je vous propose qu'on puisse
commencer cette audition Messieurs les
Présidents mesdames Messieurs mes chers
collègues la délégation sénatoriale aux
outre-mer a décidé de lancer cette année
une étude sur le foncier agricole dans
les outre-mer selon le principe de
parité que nous appliquons au sein de
cette délégation et binôme de
rapporteurs a été nommé et je tiens
évidemment à remercier Vivette Lopez
c'est la matrice du Gard est à mettre
sur les lignes sénateurs de Mayotte de
cette reportée candidat pour ce rapport
et d'approfondir une problématique
essentielle à nos yeux notre délégation
c'est en effet intéressé de longue date
au problème fonciers en outre-mer et a
produit trois rapports remarqués sur
différents aspects de ce sujet au cours
des dernières années certains
territoires ont été particulièrement
touchés par une perte de terres
agricoles et une tendance à la
diminution du nombre d'exploitants sauf
en Guyane territoire pour lequel nous
aurons un focus particulier compte tenu
de sa spécificité
cette situation vous paraît très
préoccupante compte tenu des enjeux
d'autosuffisance alimentaire et de
transformation écologique qui sont
devant nous le Salon International de
l'Agriculture qui se tient en ce moment
Porte de Versailles sont fait largement
l'écho donc c'est audition tombe à point
nommé et je pense qu'il y avait pas de
comment monter en l'occurrence et mais
bien le sentiment d'une nécessité pour
la délégation de se pencher sur ce
travail et merci à Victoire jasmin
d'avoir suggéré ce thème d'études nous
engageons donc ce matin une série
d'auditions consacrées plus
particulièrement au fonciers agricole
outre-mer pour nous aider à comprendre
la mesure des difficultés auxquelles un
territoire sont confrontés nous avons
fait appel à la Fédération nationale des
sociétés d'aménagement fonciers et
d'établissement rural et dont les
responsables sont fortement mobilisés
sur ces questions et nous les remercions
évidemment de leur disponibilité
nous accueillons donc ce matin Monsieur
Manuel yest son président accompagné de
Madame Sabina gaufroy chargé de relation
publique et internationale
monsieur Rodrigue trèfle le président de
la SAFER de Guadeloupe et Monsieur
Robert Catherine directeur de la SAFER
de Martinique soyez toutes et tous les
bienvenus vous allez avoir la parole
dans l'ordre que j'ai annoncé pour une
dizaine une douzaine de minutes on a un
peu de temps ce matin donc on peut
prendre le temps de poser les choses et
puis par la suite je laisserai le temps
de parole au rapporteur sur la base
d'une trame qui vous a été adressée et
sur laquelle d'ailleurs nous sommes
plutôt preneurs également de support
écrits et de toute contribution
notamment par exemple comme les plans
d'activités qui ont été arrêtés qui
permettront d'alimenter les travaux des
rapporteurs
je vous remercie donc et je vous laisse
dès maintenant la parole pour aux propos
liminaires avant de laisser la parole au
rapporteur puis par la suite à nos
collègues alors bonjour mesdames et
messieurs tout d'abord je tiens à
m'excuser donc de du retard de ce matin
on a eu bon un petit peu de difficulté
peut-être un peu manque d'habitude aussi
de la part de nos collègues alors bien
évidemment on est tout à fait très
heureux de participer à cette audition
pour la FNSE affaire les affaires des
Outre-mer font partie intégrante des
affaires du territoire national on a
même modifié notre façon de travailler
pour changer nos statuts à une certaine
époque pour que les difficultés liées au
déplacement et autres qui engendraient
des coûts supplémentaires font
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble de ces coups
sont pris en charge par la Fédération ce
qui permet une plus grande fluidité et
Rodrigue trèf qui est ici présent et le
président du groupe des affaires
outre-mer et donc participe à nos
travaux de nos bureaux
les affaires des Outre-mer
[Musique]
a fortiori sur des territoires
ultramarins sont souvent les premiers
confrontés à ce changement climatique et
donc à une nécessaire adaptation de de
leur agriculture vous l'avez souligné
dans vos propos une baisse des du nombre
d'hectares sur ces territoires qui sont
exigus donc à chaque fois qu'on baisse
on baisse le potentiel d'autonomie
alimentaire du territoire souvent alors
je mes collègues le diront mais je le
dis moi on en vient on a fait un conseil
d'administration décentralisée aux
Antilles il y a un mois beaucoup de
présidents de s'affaires métropolitaine
de connaissait pas les Antilles en
découvert les spécificités
l'enjeu lié à l'agriculture et aussi un
enjeu de développement économique
puisque le tourisme est souvent très
très lié à la façon dont l'agriculture
peut être dynamique sur un territoire et
aussi produire de l'alimentation je
pense que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui qui qui vont en voyage aujourd'hui
apprécient d'avoir une
une agriculture de proximité donc il y a
véritable enjeu il y a un enjeu majeur
aujourd'hui de renouvellement des
générations comme partout sur le
territoire mais je pense là je parle
sous leur couvert mais pour puisqu'on en
a discuté il y a vraiment pas longtemps
encore plus fort là très nettement la
pyramide des âges et plus importante
encore dans les affaires des Outre-mer
que partout ailleurs sur le territoire
national
un vrai enjeu c'est vrai partout mais à
fortiori dans des territoires où le taux
de chômage est plus important
qu'ailleurs
une vraie responsabilité à partir du
moment où on forme des jeunes dans des
lycées agricoles d'avoir la capacité des
accompagner pour pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre leur métier parce que ça c'est
aussi un vrai enjeu moi je je le trouve
partout mais à fortiori sur ces
territoires où il y a moins de travail
puisqu'il y a plus de chômage être
capable de faire la place à des nouveaux
jeunes qui souhaitent entrer dans le
métier d'agriculteur c'est c'est un
point vraiment important et puis je
m'arrêterai là pas parce que je suis pas
un spécialiste même si je connais bien
puisque j'ai été huit ans administrateur
de la SAFER Guadeloupe pour accompagner
le président et et vous parliez tout à
l'heure et je vais en dire un mot tout
de suite et puis ça permettra si vous
avez des questions concernant la Guyane
la Guyane est un territoire où il n'y
avait pas de safer parce
qu'historiquement
l'État était propriétaire de quasiment
la totalité du territoire et donc nous
sommes nous avons mis en place une safer
en Guyane depuis maintenant deux ans
avec un peu de difficulté de mise en
route je vous cache pas mais les choses
vont s'arranger et donc sur ce
territoire où il y a véritable enjeu ou
c'est presque paradoxal mais c'est un
territoire énorme avec une surface
agricole qui est finalement très très
proche des autres territoires
d'outre-mer il y a en gros entre 30 et
40 000 hectares agricoles et c'est ce
qu'on a à peu près l'ensemble des
territoires donc malgré les 8 millions
d'hectares de territoire il y a une
surface agricole faible et un véritable
enjeu là aussi de d'autonomie
alimentaire et puis un enjeu de sécurité
publique parce que c'est pour ça qu'on
nous a aussi appuyé pour mettre en place
cette affaire avec un un accaparement et
des constructions illégales à beaucoup
d'endroits avec tous les enjeux que de
sécurité publique que ça peut engendrer
donc et puis le dernier point je
souhaitais soulever dans mon propos
liminaire et on l'a dit des territoires
exiguës et l'exiguité des territoires
fait que les ressources des affaires des
territoires d'outre-mer sont limités
puisque aujourd'hui vous le savez les
affaires ne bénéficient plus d'aucun
soutien public hormis
une enveloppe spécifique pour les
territoires d'outre-mer mais qui est
limité et qui n'est pas suffisante
aujourd'hui et qui engendre des
difficultés de gestion au directeur
puisque il faut tous les ans aller
réclamer auprès des collectivités
territoriales qui jouent un jeu qui qui
d'accompagnement qu'il faut souligner
puisque
elles apportent au budget des affaires
pour leur permettre de boucler leur
budget mais ça reste malgré tout très
fragile puisque c'est soumis au vote du
budget des collectivités territoriales
et à tout moment la collectivité
pourrait être amené à faire un arbitrage
pour ne pas pouvoir faire cette
subvention de fonctionnement et la SAFER
ne pourrait pas boucler son budget et
donc on ne pourrait pas mettre en oeuvre
la politique publique de de contrôle et
de régulation sur le territoire donc je
pense et on a des idées on pourrait en
discuter sur un mode de financement
particulier qui qui serait sur pour
financer des affaires d'hommes
évidemment on ne souhaite pas du tout
qui est de modification sur le reste du
territoire national voilà ce que je
pouvais vous dire et Rodrigue peut
peut-être préciser
ah d'accord excusez-moi bon bonjour à
tous très bien déjà je vous remercie
donc de cette invitation pour nous
permettre de nous exprimer sur la
problématique foncière en outre-mer
comme vous savez nous sommes donc sous
sur les villes pour la plupart sur de
Guyane avec des obligations comme on le
fait avec les événements dernièrement
pas fait pour le covid qui tient encore
révélé plus fortement la nécessité pour
nous de pouvoir subvenir à nos propres
besoins alimentaires aujourd'hui les des
collectivités majeures chez nous ils ont
pris l'orientation effectivement de de
s'assurer que là que tu guadeloupéenne
pourra subvenir aux besoins des des
Guadeloupéens il est vrai que l'outil
que représente les affaires peut-être
également en Guadeloupe est un outil
capital il faut savoir que là ça fait le
Guadeloupe dans les dans les 40
dernières années on a on a on a dû
initier une politique publique de l'État
qui était la cette réforme représente
aujourd'hui
à peu près 8000 hectares de terre où on
installe
700 agriculteurs et représente 25% de la
de la Saï de Guadeloupe vous voyez le
proie le poids économique que Kinshasa
fait en outre-mer peut porter pour
accompagner le développement économique
il est vrai que les il y a aujourd'hui
quand même des enjeux aussi
naturellement pour la modernité
territoire pour pouvoir permettre
l'activité économique haute que
l'agriculture puisse se développer on a
eu ces dernières ces dernières années la
chance que c'est mise en place pour la
volonté de l'État de cdp-9 qui a un avis
conforme alors c'est ta vie conforme a
permis quand même en Guadeloupe de façon
plus régulière de protéger on a gagné en
souffrent agricole on a gagné à peu près
800 hectares c'est-à-dire que en
Guadeloupe il y avait quand même
malheureusement une une utilisation
d'espace qui était faite un peu de façon
consommatrice de
on a pu protéger donc cet outil qui est
pour moi essentiel pour maintenir des
terres nonitées puisque c'est aussi pour
ceux qui peut-être pas parmi vous qui
ont pu aller en Guadeloupe l'élément
fort dès qu'on arrive sur notre île en
avion on va quand même il y a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de construction ont
fait et parsemés dans les territoires
agricoles ça nécessite naturellement une
protection particulière plus
régulièrement chez nous puisque notre
agriculture comme peut-être vous le
savez que j'ai quand même qui est
relativement jeune puisque c'est il y a
moyen siècle qu'on a vraiment pu mettre
en place des agricultures de type
familial comme ça ici en métropole voilà
donc c'est à dire qu'on a pas là on
n'avait pas la culture des cultures
recentrer sur la la production pour la
population
on est issu d'une agriculture basée sur
la production pour la métropole à
travers la canne et la banane donc c'est
récemment quand même que que vraiment
on a plus
voir l'obligation de diversifier nos
agriculture et de permettre de créer des
filières qui se mettent en place pour
pouvoir répondre à aux attentes des
Guadeloupe il est vrai aussi que non
agriculture jeune malgré aussi l'élément
comme qui est pas en notre faveur avec
un âge très élevé de nos exploitants
agricoles le gros défi de de
l'agriculture de la Guadeloupe également
c'est d'arriver à faire une transition
pour arriver puisque là l'âge moyen chez
nous c'est 57 ans c'est-à-dire qu'on a
une obligation rapidement de maîtriser
le foncier de permettre l'accès aux
foncier aux jeunes aux jeunes et ça
c'est quand même les enjeux de demain
pour la Guadeloupe puisque on voit bien
on a pu quand j'ai dit tout à l'heure
préservé la FAU on n'a pas eu de perte
de saü c'est ces dix dernières années
mais néanmoins avec les éléments
d'actualité que nous subissons
actuellement on sent quand même qu'il y
a une diminution de cette zone de
production du fait que les coûts de
production sont beaucoup plus élevés ils
revenus dégager pour permettre
d'agriculteurs de de vivre et à moins de
vie et là on sent depuis un an et une
tendance à ce que à avoir des parcelles
qui sont un peu abandonnés ou bien mal
cultivés ou voir en friche mais comme je
le répéterai il est nécessaire par
contre le conforter cette protection du
Foss agricole et là comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure le président yes la
problématique de première contrairement
à des affaires ici qui opèrent de grands
espaces on a un problème de d'économie
c'est-à-dire que je pense pas que le
marché de foncier de la Guadeloupe ou
les autres domaines permettront de
pouvoir
générer suffisamment de ressources pour
pouvoir mettre en place des équipes
financer les équipes et c'est vrai ça a
été dit tout à l'heure
on ne contient de se rapprocher des
collectivités et c'est quand même un
élément un peu sensible insensible
puisque bon je crois que ce serait
bienvenu que l'État puisse assurer une
pérennité financière de ces
situations-là parce que bon il s'agit
quand même de l'autonomie alimentaire et
à mon sens c'est le domaine quand même
de l'état de s'assurer que la population
puisse avoir
les denrées voilà donc là dessus je
pense que c'est très bien ce serait bien
de mentionner cet aspect financement des
affaires d'outre avec un appui voilà
voilà ce que je peux dire déjà en
préambule et on attend on va répondre à
toutes vos interrogations
je suis le directeur de la saphir
Martinique et donc je vais pas reprendre
les propos du président yes du président
Rodrigue trèfle puisque c'est exactement
les mêmes problématiques qui s'opposent
chez nous de manière un peu plus accrue
pour la Martinique parce que
les superficie vous savez que les saphir
ne peuvent intervenir que sur les
notifications qu'elles ont reçu c'est à
partir de ce moment que on prend la main
entre guillemets
et grosso modo la Martinique c'est moins
de 500 notifications par an
c'est si je compare avec les pays de la
loi c'est 23000 notifications c'est pour
vous
une idée de ce que ça peut représenter
donc c'est sans notifications grosso
modo 500 hectares en notifié par année
comme je viens de le dire le président
Trump c'est pas avec ça qu'on va qu'on
va pouvoir
équilibrer nos comptes à supposer
compris surtout surtout si nous est
notifié ce qui n'est pas le cas
donc ce sont des outils qui sont
nécessaires voire indispensables mais
qui sont très fragiles financièrement
parce que
on n'a pas toujours la capacité
financière à
réaliser les préemptions qu'on voudrait
faire je vous donne un exemple la loi la
dernière loi la lave permet de faire une
préemption partielle c'est à dire qu'on
vend une maison avec deux hectares
la Safia la possibilité de faire une
présentation potentielle c'est-à-dire
qu'elle découpe du millimètre carré
autour de la maison et elle priente le
solde souvent ce sont des maisons qui
sont vendues à 500 800.000 euros ça fait
un appel à la capacité ça fait
Martinique t'as pas la capacité de faire
cette préemption par contre si on fait
si on fait le découpage et comme le prix
moyen 50 centimes d'euros du mètre carré
on a cette capacité à pouvoir intervenir
sauf que dans la loi le propriétaire
vendeur a la possibilité de dire là ça
fait acheter
votre découpage je n'en veux pas acheter
le acheter le bien ça nous arrive
souvent y compris pour des biens pour
lesquels sur lesquels on s'est mis
d'accord avec le Conservatoire du
littoral par exemple parce que on est à
Carrefour on travaille pas que pour nous
et bien on n'arrive pas à suivre
ce sont les exemples que nous avons
autre problématique pour la Martinique
c'est le vieillissement de de des
agriculteurs on a on est c'est pas pour
rien qu'on est conservateur le plus
vieux département de France donc ça
serait percute sur la sur les sur la
population agricole
et puis surtout il y a des jeunes
agricultures qui sont formés ça coûte
très cher de former les jeunes
agricultures
sauf qu'il y a une chose essentielle qui
manque c'est que ils ont la capacité
littéraire
théorique mais la capacité
du fils de paysan qui a grandi les pieds
dans la boue qui a enregis qui
enregistre au fil de ces années des
gestes séculaires nous ça on n'a pas ça
et donc il y a un mécanisme à mettre en
place à inventer pour faire un peu une
forme de pépinière d'entreprise agricole
de façon à ce que les jeunes
agricultures une fois qu'ils sont sortis
du lecteur qu'ils ont leur diplôme ils
puissent ils puissent
s'appuyer sur une une
expérience professionnelle réelle
la tout le reste est théorique si vous
voulez
donc ça c'est une vraie problématique
l'autre problématique qu'on a c'est que
c'est une population qui a une très
faible capacité financière
et là saphir tant en rétrocession que en
location est obligé est obligé de se
garantir la capacité de vouloir payer
ses loyers ou de voir payer son son le
bien qu'elle doit qu'elle veut être
aussi dit donc ça ça rallonge les
procédures on est en train de mettre des
mécanismes de portage avec une organisme
qui est le Crédit Agricole à la
Martinique
on a passé des conventions aussi avec
les EPF pour essayer de trouver des
capacités
permettre aux jeunes d'agriculture santé
les diplômés de pouvoir accéder aux
fonciers aux fonciers agricoles
la collectivité a mis en place un autre
mécanisme qui est la banque on appelle
la banque de tiers de la collectivité
la limite de ce mécanisme là c'est que à
terme l'agriculture ne sera toujours que
pour que le locataire donc c'est une
possibilité mais il faut pas que ça soit
la seule il faut qu'il connaît panel de
solutions à proposer aux jeunes
agricultures
voilà ce que je peux dire rapidement
pour vous sensibiliser autre chose sur
le
Rodrigue Glady sur le sur les outils qui
existent qui sont très bien comme la
cdp9 c'est un outil exceptionnel mais
contre lequel se battre les élus locaux
bien sûr parce que c'est le côté le côté
le côté conforme ne leur convient pas
nous le convient pas donc ils ont
demandé ils ont demandé la suppression
de de cet outil si ça si ça se passait
ce serait ce serait un gros recul pour
la peau
la cdp9 un handicap selon moi c'est que
c'est oui ou non on peut pas négocier la
Martinique on fait des présides c'est à
dire on se met d'accord en entend les
collectivités on se met d'accord on leur
explique c'est qui bien ce qui est pas
bien à nos yeux de ses dépenses et très
souvent on arrive à trouver un
comédie de façon à
à ne pas bloquer la commune qui a besoin
de réaliser ces projets de développement
et en même temps préserver le foncier
agricole il s'agit pas d'être dit à
yatoulas qui qui sont tout pour un il
faut il faut le développement partout la
Saphira une de ses missions c'est
protéger le français agricole mais aussi
c'est travailler sur le développement
local donc il faut il faut toujours
avoir une retenue dans dans les options
qu'on prend il y a un autre point que je
voulais que je voulais
attirer c'est la perte de foncier à la
Martinique c'est on ne récupère pas le
foncier
pour vous donner une idée en 1960 on
était à 80 000 hectares de saü
aujourd'hui on est à 22000 hectares
donc la perte pendant longtemps été 2000
hectares par an sur un tout petit
territoire de 2101 km²
on est arrivé à corriger avec la cdp9
mais on perd quand même encore 700 800
hectares donc on est en bonne voie mais
c'est le mal n'est pas n'est pas n'est
pas mon et
on a quand même une chance parce qu'il
faut pas avoir une vision négative on a
quand même une chance à la Martinique
c'est que on a à peu près 30 000
hectares 20 000 hectares de tir en
fruits ce sont des terres anciennement
agricoles sur lesquels on pourrait faire
jouer la lutte la loi existe c'est
l'application qu'il faut qu'il faut
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre c'est de la
lutte contre les terres en friche ou
insuffisamment cultivé le ou
insuffisamment cultivé est important
c'est l'option qui nous qui
nous est ouvert aujourd'hui
si je peux me permettre d'ajouter sur ce
point qui est un point pour moi crucial
sur l'ensemble des territoires mais
particulièrement en Martinique puisqu'on
l'a déjà mis en oeuvre à la demande de
Robert Catherine j'étais intervenu à il
y a un climat on disait tout à l'heure
qui est particulier donc le la
végétation développe plus vite quand on
laisse en friche qu'ailleurs et on a on
est confronté l'affaire est confronté en
fait à une interprétation de l'ONF
qui empêche de remettre en culture des
terres qu'il l'était et c'est un vrai
problème parce que c'était des terres
agricoles les photos aériennes le
démontrent et donc j'étais intervenu à
l'époque auprès du directeur de l'ONF on
avait réussi à régler une partie du
problème mais c'est pas passé pas la
solution il faut pas que c'est pas le
rôle du président de l'iPhone s'affaire
d'appeler le directeur de l'ONF et de
régler alors que l'enjeu c'est de se
donner une doctrine qui permet
après photo interprétation de dire que
les terres qui étaient agricoles elles
doivent le redevenir si elles avaient
été abandonnées à un moment donné et par
contre parce que c'était le sujet qui
est souvent qui nous est souvent opposé
bien évidemment en prenant toutes les
précautions sur les problématiques
environnementales là où il y a des
problèmes de ravine ou autre évidemment
que ces endroits là seront pas défricher
mais mais les terres qui sont à plates
et qui peuvent être à plat et qui
peuvent être occupés par l'agriculture
il faut le faire donc c'est c'est un
vrai enjeu spécifique là sur les
territoires d'outre-mer il est un peu
moins prégnant en Guadeloupe mais il est
malgré tout aussi et on l'a aussi la
réunion n'est pas là mais cette
problématique existe aussi chez eux et
la remarque que faisait Robert Catherine
tout à l'heure sur les possibilités
d'intervention sur les biens mixtes avec
des préemptions partielles il y a
exactement la même remarque qui nous le
font souvent remonter le prix du bâti
est tel que la saferme ne peut pas se
permettre
d'acquérir la totalité du bien c'est
prendre trop de risques
donc là il y a un vrai sujet de
réflexion à avoir
merci pour vos remarques liminaire je
vais mettre en laisser la parole à nos
rapporteurs et puis par la suite on peut
le faire de manière interactive pour
qu'il y a une certaine dynamique ce sera
quand même plus plus sympathique pour
tout le monde je pense
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs bonjour
c'est très intéressant ce que vous nous
dites je voudrais rebondir là sur ce que
vous venez de dire concernant la
Martinique que vous aviez donc 80 000
hectares de terre et qui vous en reste
actuellement
22000 dont 2000 ou apparemment en friche
alors pour quelle raison ONF donc
empêcherait quelles sont les raisons
profondes est-ce que si les moi
j'aimerais savoir si les contraintes
européennes sur les produits sanitaires
parce que bon aujourd'hui il y a quand
même pas mal de contraintes sont un
frein aussi pour que les gens
s'installent vous avez également signalé
que aujourd'hui beaucoup de
terres agricoles sont cultivés par des
personnes d'un certain âge mais est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup de demandes de la
part des jeunes est-ce que les jeunes
sont vraiment demandeurs ou pas est-ce
que le besoin de logement
ne prend pas le pas sur les agricole
parce que j'ai cru comprendre que il y
avait à certains endroits on
construisait des immeubles pour loger
les gens mais que les gens ne veulent
pas de cela légèrement préfèrent avoir
leur petite maison individuelles et que
vous vous retrouvez avec des immeubles
les appartements où les gens ne veulent
pas aller donc est-ce que ça aussi n'est
pas quand même un handicap
[Musique]
oui
Messieurs les Présidents madame
messieurs de la Fédération nationale de
safer c'est vraiment un plaisir de vous
avoir ici aujourd'hui et merci beaucoup
de de votre présence c'est bien de
commencer par vous vous allez pouvoir
pouvoir nous accélérer
en ce qui me concerne
c'est un plaisir de reprendre du service
puisque j'ai eu l'honneur et la joie de
coordonnées les trois rapports sur le
foncier en général outre-mer de 2015 à
2017 qui ont donné une étude
transversale de la situation de blocage
et de tension du foncier
ultramarin et finalement cette étude sur
le Fossier agricole ça disponibilité ou
ça arrive faction ça dépend à partir
d'où on se place c'est une suite une
suite une suite logique ce n'est pas à
vous que je vais rappeler les crises
sans précédent coup sur coup de la covid
aujourd'hui de la guerre en
Ukraine qui impacte fortement sur nos
collectivités et qui mettent à jour en
fait la nécessité qui a toujours existé
mais là encore de façon plus
de l'autosuffisance à alimenter on ne
peut plus continuer dans nos territoires
à dépendre à plus de 80% pour certains
d'importation et notamment
d'importations de de produits
alimentaires et ces crises ont mis un
évidence le fait qu'il fallait que l'on
arrête que l'on arrête avec avec ces
pratiques et finalement
[Musique]
moi j'aimerais commencer que vous
commenciez même si c'est une évidence
pour vous par rappeler
pourquoi les affaires
une raison d'exister c'est un peu dans
le prolongement des questions les
surfaces agricoles
utiles
dans chaque dans chaque territoire et
pourquoi il y a une nécessité importante
impérieuse que les affaires existent
dans tous les territoires où vous le
savez
parmi les départements d'outre-mer il y
en a un ou la SAFER n'existe pas alors
c'est Mayotte et monsieur le Président
Yeste vous m'avez particulièrement
intéressé en rappelant qu'il y a deux
ans vous avez mis en place la SAFER de
Guyane
qu'est-ce que en termes de d'expérience
vous pourriez doser déjà nous dire
d'autant plus que les mêmes
les mêmes contraintes
qui existent en Guyane se pose aussi à
Mayotte une pression
démographique
excessive exceptionnelles et je suis
désolé de d'insister sur mon département
mais il ne fait que il ne fait que 374
km²
avec aujourd'hui 300 000 habitants
officiellement et on sait que faut
ajouter
40% 50% de plus et dans ces conditions
les missions de la SAFER sont exercées
par l'établissement public foncier et
d'aménagement et moi je loue le travail
que fait cet établissements publics mais
un gun aussi il y a un établissement
public foncier d'aménagement de Guyane
et pourtant la nécessité d'une safer
du fait jour donc
quels sont selon vous les les raisons
qui pourraient aujourd'hui
être avancé pour dire que une safer
serait aussi serait aussi nécessaire
dans dans ce département et puis dans
les autres territoires aussi est-ce que
pour vous
la nécessité d'avoir une safer se fait
jour
partout dans dans
les collectivités d'outre-mer je
rappelle que
le
les missions
censées être
exercée par la SAFER à Mayotte le son
par l'établissement public foncier
d'aménagement est-ce que vous trouvez
que c'est compatible ou vraiment il y
aurait nécessité d'avoir une affaire la
question peut-être délicate mais
vraiment je la pose en toute objectivité
et en saluant le travail que fait
aujourd'hui l'établissement public et
foncier d'aménagement à Mayotte voilà
je m'arrête là pour l'instant mais
vraiment nous comptons sur vous pour
nous éclairer sur votre organisation
alors merci beaucoup il y a beaucoup de
questions intéressantes alors on va on
va commencer par la dernière
l'enjeu des affaires rappeler l'enjeu
des affaires les affaires elles ont été
créés en 1960 à une époque elle n'avait
qu'un rôle agricole et c'est pour ça que
souvent on nous dit oui mais il y a trop
de monde agricoles dans la gouvernance
des affaires mais c'est parce
qu'historiquement il y avait qu'une
mission agricole très rapidement le
législateur à élargi à au développement
local à l'accompagnement du
développement des territoires avec
notamment tout ce qui est grand ouvrages
depuis les 30 40 dernières années il y a
pas eu un ouvrage linéaire où la SAFER
n'a pas participé à sa mise en oeuvre et
quand on voit il suffit de regarder ce
qui s'est passé je prends un exemple qui
est emblématique que tout le monde
connaît Notre-Dame-des-Landes la SAFER
n'avait pas été missionné 50 ans de 50
ans de projets et et finalement une
reculade pour pour aboutir à rien
l'occurrence pouvoir dire que
l'accompagnement des affaires sur le
territoire sur tous ces développements
de de d'ouvrage Liné à autres a permis
un double résultat d'aboutir à ce que
les ouvrages se mettent en place à un
coût moindre pour la collectivité
nationale puisque c'est souvent l'État
qui dans ses ouvrages linéaires qui
étaient le financeur puisque on n'est
pas dans une problématique
d'expropriation et la prise en compte de
l'intérêt des agriculteurs puisque le
rôle des affaires dans ce cadre là c'est
d'acquérir du foncier dans les
dans les surfaces qui correspondent à ce
que va perdre dans l'agriculture
donc on est on est missionné pendant
pendant des années donner un exemple
actuel la ville de Rouen je suis je suis
président de safer en Normandie la ville
de Rouen est une des seules métropoles
françaises aujourd'hui qui n'a pas de
déviation les gens rentrent encore en
plein centre-ville avec les camions on
doit mettre en oeuvre ça fait partie des
des priorités que l'État a rappelé on a
mis l'hectare de réserve foncière
qui vont servir à la fois donc à faire
l'ouvrage mais aussi à compenser les
agriculteurs qui eux n'ont rien demandé
et qui sont sur l'emplacement du du
passage donc ça c'est vraiment la
mission majeure des affaires aujourd'hui
alors la différence qui peut y avoir
entre un établissement public foncier et
la SAFER on pourrait nous poser pourquoi
c'est pas les EPF qui le font c'est que
les affaires elles ont un grand avantage
c'est qu'elles accompagnent avec le
prisme agricole toujours quand on
accompagne une collectivité pour dégager
une emprise pour faire une zone
industrielle par exemple on va nous
systématiquement regarder quels sont les
enjeux pour l'agriculture tout à l'heure
c'était c'était dit Robert Catherine le
disait l'accompagnement avec les
collectivités on peut très bien être
amené à dire à une collectivité bah non
votre zone économique c'est pas là qu'il
faut la mettre parce que c'est l'endroit
où il y a les meilleurs terres du
territoire parce que c'est là où il y a
éventuellement la meilleure réserve en
eau et par contre à surface équivalente
consommée il vaut mieux que vous vous
mettiez un autre endroit parce qu'on va
vous accompagner là et on va pouvoir le
faire donc ça c'est vraiment l'enjeu la
grosse différence qui peut y avoir entre
un établissement public foncier parce
que je vous cache pas parce que il y a
des élus agricoles et ça c'est c'est
aussi cette grande force des affaires
moi je je suis très très régulièrement
appelé à montrer pour avec des pays
étrangers ou autres et cette la
complémentarité qu'il y a entre une
direction et et des collaborateurs et
puis un conseil d'administration où il y
a des professionnels dedans il y a et
au-delà dans nos conseils
d'administration il y a les
collectivités territoriales il y a les
collectivités locales il y a les
associations de protection de
l'environnement en fait il y a il y a
l'ensemble des usagers des territoires
ruraux qui sont au sein de conseils
d'administration et de nos comités
techniques et ça ça fait j'en suis
vraiment persuadé c'est ce qui fait la
différence
donc ça ça c'est alors après en Guyane
on a été amené à la mettre en place elle
est pas encore opérationnelle donc je
peux pas vous donner le résultat elle
est pas encore opérationnelle mais mais
l'enjeu enfin j'y retourne là dans 15
jours parce que bon toujours un peu
compliqué la mise en place sur un
territoire où il y en a jamais eu voilà
les habitudes se sont prises on va le
mettre en place
je sais avoir été sollicité à plusieurs
reprises par rapport à Mayotte
et et la prochaine fois que je me
déplace à la Réunion c'est prévu j'ai
rencontré des élus mahorais et on va
aller sur le territoire pour voir un
petit peu comment on peut éventuellement
accompagner dans un premier temps je
suis pas sûr qu'on proposera une safer
mais ce qui est pressenti c'est que les
équipes de la Réunion puisse être en
support l'équipe qui serait sur le
territoire de Mayotte pour justement
essayer de mettre en place un début de
régulation qui se rapprocherait
éventuellement évidemment en
accompagnement de de l'établissement
public foncier mais pour voir comment
comment on peut faire et puis surtout
moi je
je quand on fait quelque chose on va sur
place pour voir avant les les bien
comprendre les problématiques parce que
parce que si on connaît pas les
problématiques c'est plus difficile de
trouver des solutions
un mot par exemple dans les caisses les
différentes questions je vais reprendre
puis après je laisserai seul ou je suis
pas capable de répondre par exemple sur
le Conservatoire du littoral c'est c'est
le Conservatoire du littoral c'est un
vrai partenaire des affaires partout sur
le territoire national on travaille avec
eux j'ai renouvelé une convention
nationale l'année dernière une
convention cadre qui donc s'applique
partout sur le territoire je peux dire
parce que je sais qu'il y a eu des des
terrains qui ont été vendus il y a pas
très très longtemps par la Guadeloupe
aujourd'hui on entretient des très très
bonnes relations avec eux il y a eu une
évolution dans la gouvernance
et surtout dans la dans la la réflexion
scientifique du conservateur du littoral
qui aujourd'hui
reconnaît qu'il vaut mieux qu'il y ait
de l'agriculture
qu'il n'y a rien sur son territoire donc
partout on peut le faire on met de
l'agriculture en convention avec eux
c'est nous qui leur proposons les
agriculteurs qui vont pouvoir exploiter
les terrains du conservatoire et souvent
c'est les affaires qui attribuent au
Conservatoire les terrains dont ils sont
propriétaires on a vraiment une relation
très très forte et il y a que là où il y
a pas d'enjeu agricole du tout il y a
des endroits où c'est impossible de
faire de l'agriculture ou là on reste
spécifiquement conservatoire mais mais
on travaille bien avec eux alors
pourquoi pourquoi il y a une raison
d'être de la SAFER je le disais tout à
l'heure on a on a un enjeu donc agricole
qui est un enjeu de régulation du prix
du foncier
quand on explique ça c'est pas forcément
facile à comprendre on s'inscrit dans le
marché c'est-à-dire que souvent les gens
nous disent ah mais vous le prix des
terres augmente bah oui il augmente on
est en France
on n'est pas dans un pays totalitaire où
on a décidé que le marché était fermé
donc la SAFER elle s'inscrit dans le
marché mais elle le régule c'est à dire
que son rôle c'est d'éviter que il y ait
des emballements qu'on est des bulles
spéculatives ou que quelqu'un qui par
exemple aurait beaucoup d'argent sur un
territoire n'importe où ils disent ben
moi je suis beaucoup plus riche que les
autres et c'est moi qui achète tout en
mettant en achetant hors du prix ça
c'est impossible aujourd'hui sur le
territoire national la SAFER elle
intervient par son droit de prévention
sauf si on est dans des sociétés où là
on peut pas le faire
quand on est dans une société et je vous
en dirai un petit mot tout à l'heure
parce que la loi s'en passe tout qui a
été votée en 2021 elle s'applique depuis
hier matin
donc la mise en œuvre ça commence depuis
le 1er mars
mais donc on régule alors avec
évidemment des trous dans la raquette
comme le disait tout à l'heure Robert
Catherine vous avez une propriété bâtie
et puis vous avez autour des terrains
agricoles si la propriété bâti pèse
tellement lourd par rapport au fonciers
que on peut pas intervenir et ben là
effectivement il y a un trou
c'est ça fait il y a encore un certain
nombre de trous mais bon
moi j'ai toujours tendance à dire qu'il
faut regarder plutôt le verre à moitié
plein qu'à moitié vide et aujourd'hui on
a des outils qui fonctionnent et si 80%
de nos objectifs sont réalisés ben il
faut qu'on s'améliore mais on est quand
même globalement avec un outil qui nous
permet de réguler d'intervenir tout en
respectant la capacité des gens à
entreprendre à pouvoir se développer
c'est aussi un rôle important de un rôle
d'équilibre et notre régulation on la
voit vraiment comme ça à quelque chose
d'équilibré
[Musique]
alors on présente souvent peu les gens
voient souvent la SAFER de l'extérieur
comme étant un outil de préemption on
reçoit plus de 320 000 déclarations
d'intention d'aliénés par an donc c'est
énorme
comparaison des 500 euros reçoivent mon
voisin de la Martinique 320 000 on
préempte moins de 1% de ces déclarations
d'attention d'aliné qu'on reçoit et
c'est 1% qui sont préemptés représente
en gros 10% de notre activité
donc 90% de l'activité des affaires
partout y compris sur les territoires
d'outre-mer se fait à l'amiable même
s'il y a un petit peu plus de préemption
sur les territoires d'outre-mer
alors
qu'est-ce que je peux alors sur
l'autonomie alimentaire je pense que ça
c'est vraiment un enjeu majeur vous
l'avez souligné monsieur sénateur les
deux dernières crises l'ont mis encore
plus en avant et sur un territoire qui
est souvent seul par définition puisque
c'est une île cette autonomie
alimentaire elle est encore plus
prégnante et pour je vais vous donner on
a accompagné
là on n'est pas sur un territoire
d'outre-mer on est sur un pays souverain
c'est Malte qui nous a demandé il y a
deux ans on a fait un accompagnement
justement pour
on a fait un transfert de compétences en
fait avec Malte sur comment on travaille
en France qu'est-ce qui pourrait être
mis en place avec eux parce qu'ils ont
un territoire très très exigu et ils
sont aussi très inquiets vous voyez
c'est je pense que c'est une vraie
réflexion partout de se dire s'il se
passait quelque chose combien de temps
on a devant nous pour pour se nourrir et
donc là nous vraiment c'est une démarche
qu'on
d'accompagnement qu'on fait avec les
avec les affaires et on se dit souvent
s'il y avait pas cet outil de régulation
qu'est-ce qui se passerait
et donc c'est pour ça que la réflexion
sur le financement du service public des
affaires sur un territoire ultramarin
elle est elle est vraiment indispensable
parce que vous imaginez que vous qui
l'avez malheureusement sur votre
territoire où il y a pas de safer et ben
l'intervention elle est beaucoup plus
difficile et on a surtout un problème
qui est un problème réel qu'on a déjà en
Guyane c'est que quand on va commencer à
intervenir on est sur un marché qui n'a
pas de référence
et donc la première fois où on va
préempter avec révision de prix pour
dire voilà on considère que le prix de
référence il doit être à peu près
celui-là je suis à peu près persuadé
qu'on va être attaqué au tribunal où les
gens vont nous dire mais attendez il y a
pas de référence vous dites que c'est
pas le prix moi je vous conteste et donc
il faut aussi là que les affaires on
soit assez solide pour que on puisse
supporter une éventuelle à une
éventuelle condamnation devant une
juridiction ça nous arrive de et là en
l'occurrence pour créer la nouvelle
référence
y compris donc demain s'il y avait
quelque chose à Mayotte il faudra qu'on
ait qu'on prenne des références et qu'on
prenne des risques et on le fait c'est
notre rôle mais on est en train de
demander
ça fait partie des sujets sur lesquels
on est en réflexion il y a on a peu de
demandes sur les affaires au niveau
national considère qu'aujourd'hui la loi
est à peu près bien organisée pour nous
mais on a un sujet sur lesquels on a des
évolution où on souhaiterait demander
c'est qu'il puisse y avoir de temps en
temps peut-être une caution de l'état de
garantie de l'État sur l'intervention
des affaires qui permettent quand on a
des opérations à risque que ça soit pas
là ça faire qu'ils prennent le risque
tout seul mais qui est derrière une
caution d'État qui permette d'intervenir
notamment dans les dans les dans les
opérations comme disait Robert Catherine
sur des préemptions partielles si la
SAFER voulait le faire
se dire je j'ai une garantie de bonne
fin en fait
voilà je pense que moi j'ai alors sur le
logement aussi il y a un point sur le
logement parce que Rodrigue pourra le
préciser mais on était ensemble je vous
disais le il y a moi environ on avait un
conseil d'administration et on a parlé
de ce sujet et on a été interpellé par
un élu local qui nous a dit oui il faut
classer des P9 n'est plus la vie
conforme
on lui a dit mais pourquoi puis David
conforme alors que on avait demandé
l'intervention et c'était très très
intéressant parce que c'était en
parallèle de la responsable de
l'établissement public foncier de
Guadeloupe qui expliquait qu'il y avait
eu des des projections d'augmentation de
population à certains niveaux qui
nécessitait justement des réserves
foncières et puis finalement on était un
peu en dessous et donc à partir du
moment où on était en dessous a priori
la demande de logement elle est moins
moins importante puisque on a besoin de
terrain quand on a une augmentation de
population et en fait là le le notre élu
local dit oui mais il y a aussi le
tourisme donc à un moment donné
effectivement si on met tout le temps
dire il y a une bonne raison pour
consommer les terres agricoles
depuis deux mois là
les terres agricoles c'est
l'alimentation c'est l'eau c'est la
réserve en eau c'est au-delà l'énergie
c'est plein de choses mais c'est d'abord
l'alimentation et l'eau et donc
aujourd'hui
à fortiori sur des territoires
contraints protéger le fossil agricole
c'est un enjeu majeur et pas pour les
agriculteurs c'est un enjeu de société
président pardonne-moi pour ne pas
perdre le fil de l'interactivité je
souhaiterais bondir sur vos propos et
vous faire une exhortation une
supplication s'il vous plaît venez avant
de tirer la moindre conclusion le
maillot et la réunion ne sont pas les
mêmes enjeux ce n'est pas le même niveau
de développement ce n'est pas le même
rythme de développement donc que vous
appuyez au départ de ce qui se passe à
la Réunion pour voir ce qui se passe à
Mayotte c'est une bonne chose mais
souvent c'est une mauvaise bonne idée
pour ne pas dire toujours une mauvaise
bonne idée de vouloir regrouper les
instances entre Mayotte et la Réunion
parce que en fait il y a un territoire
qui aspire l'autre de par son avancée de
par
son ingénierie donc c'est une
supplication que que je vous fais je
n'attends pas forcément une réponse mais
on verra comment l'organisme je sais ça
fait longtemps qu'on me réclame je vais
je vais trouver le temps pour y aller
un nouvel Calédonie par exemple
des collectivités d'outre-mer est-ce que
vous en dites alors on travaille avec la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
alors vous savez que c'est compliqué en
Nouvelle-Calédonie on a on a été on a
fait un rapport sur le foncier agricole
à la demande du gouvernement calédonien
le rapport n'a jamais été rendu public
parce que il y a eu un changement de
gouvernement et que pour l'instant il
n'est pas public on a travaillé sur
un état des lieux
sur la sortie de la DRAF la structure
qui a été mis en place pour rééquilibrer
les territoires en entre
les peuples autochtones et et les terres
privées et donc aujourd'hui on nous
avait demandé de faire donc un état des
lieux de de faire des propositions sur
comment pourrait rendre un peu plus
mobiles le foncier sur ce territoire et
c'est un enjeu a beaucoup d'endroits les
les la mise en place de beaux ruraux
fait partie des solutions qu'on peut
avoir quand on a des difficultés d'être
propriétaire les beaux ruraux
pour pour parce que moi je sais des
chiffres qui me paraissent tellement
évident mais l'agriculture française en
métropole 70% des agriculteurs sont
fermés
donc ne sont pas propriétaires des
terres qu'ils exploitent et ça pose
aucun problème
depuis 45 il y a la loi sur le statut du
fermage qui a vraiment apporté des
garanties ou fermiers
et qui permet donc de on a les mêmes
garanties que si on était propriétaire
en gros
évidemment on va vous dire on peut on
peut un jour être si le propriétaire
veut reprendre oui mais globalement
quand on est fermier on est garanti donc
c'est des propositions qu'on fait dans
notre rapport qu'on avait fait là-bas en
Calédonie en Nouvelle-Calédonie mais
comme on le fait en Guadeloupe et en
Martinique mais en Guadeloupe très
particulièrement et sur le territoire de
La Réunion où il y a eu la réforme
foncière le statut du fermage c'est
c'est un statut majeur pour pour ces
territoires parce qu'on disait des gens
ont souvent pas la capacité d'acheter
leur foncier le statut du fermage c'est
quelque chose qui qui est une réponse
voilà nous on et alors oui et on vient
pardon on vient de signer hier avec la
collectivité de Saint-Martin un
accompagnement aussi de du groupe des
affaires pour les accompagner sur la
mise en place donc de comment comment
mieux protéger les terrains agricoles
comment faire les mutations
on a une demande je vous cache pas en ce
moment enfin bon
partout en fait on accompagne aussi on
est allé moi je on le fait beaucoup sur
des l'Afrique de l'Ouest par exemple on
est on est accompagné le passage de la
mise en oeuvre en fait de loi foncière
mais vous venez de dire que 70% sont
fermés à métropole mais qu'en est-il un
outre-mer sans fermiers aussi ou son
propriétaire
alors c'est vrai que je vais rebondir
déjà pour répondre à la question de
Monsieur alors une affaire sans sa faire
en outre-mer qu'est-ce que ça pourrait
être nuire pas que ça fait quand même un
instant de conservation on a l'ensemble
des acteurs du monde rural et du monde
politique puisqu'on a au sein de notre
comité technique et du Conseil on a tous
les collectivités on a tout le tissu
rural les chambres les syndicats
vraiment c'est un espace comme qui est
faible qui arrive à se projeter on se
projette et on essaie de faire les
choses en toute concertation ou même
nous permettre une consommation
responsables dans toute intelligence
alors pour ceux qui que de chez nous je
vais quand même rappeler pour rebondir
tout l'aspect mode d'exploitation en
Guadeloupe en Guadeloupe on a on a mis
en place trois réformes il y a une
première réforme qui s'est mise en place
et là ça fait un existait pas encore
entre 60 et 68 c'est une forme c'était
les Juvigné il y avait
malheureusement
assez dégrader et ils ont dû vendre du
foncier ils se foncier était vendus
un peu à monsieur tout le monde on m'a
dit ça comme ça et ce qu'il faut 338
l'intégralité des surfaces il y avait
2800 hectares à l'époque l'intégralité
ont été urbanisées
première réforme deuxième effort qui
était dans les années 68 à
78 à peu près deuxième réforme
3900 hectares les procédé mais là c'est
un peu mixte à des colons il y a des
gens qui étaient pas forcément
agriculteurs la moitié 50% de son de ce
foncier
urbanisé et il y a eu cette troisième
réforme toujours la crise de
l'électricité puisque vous l'avez madame
la question la lecture golden la base
c'est la canne c'est quand même toute
l'espace malheureusement c'était la CAN
pour répondre aux besoins de de la
métropole en sucre cette deuxième
réforme troisième réforme on a on a on a
quand même pris un enseignement des deux
premières on s'est dit bon il y a deux
problèmes quand on retrouve cette en
pleine propriété le foncier fatalement
malheureusement ça part ça partira à la
libanisation
on a été on a fait preuve d'intelligence
on a dit on va changer le modèle on va
passer un modèle ou le l'agriculture ne
sera pas propriétaire en direct mais
sera fermier d'une entité économique une
société qu'on va créer ou lui-même sera
affaire
à hauteur bon le choix qui a été arrêté
à l'époque à hauteur de 40%, il doit 40%
de part sociale à acquérir et 60% pour
montrer la volonté quand même des
pouvoirs publics et des collectivités en
Guadeloupe les 60% des parts sociales
qui sont détenus par le logement foncé
GFA qui a été arrêté il sera détenu les
parties 60% sont devenus par là ça fait
le Crédit Agricole le département vous
voyez cette volonté quand même publique
de s'assurer qu'il y a un développement
qui va se faire sous ces espaces et là
on a pu installer effectivement plus de
700 personnes c'est 8000 hectares et la
différence
de les années 80 20 m² de terrain a été
déclassé vous voyez quand même là on a
pu concevoir l'outil le meilleur outil
pour protéger c'est l'outil sociétaire
GFA qui permettent de maintenir ces
espaces agricoles pour les générations
futures si on avait fait comme la
promener les deux premières on serait
pas on serait quand même une situation
plus dégradée
[Musique]
ce qui fait que on arrive à maintenir
une type d'agriculture un peu plus
localité puisque un terrain
Conservatoire il y a un cahier des
charges il y a des choses qu'on fait pas
c'est presque du bio presque avant
l'heure me fait c'est quand même ça
aujourd'hui c'est quand même c'est vrai
que le Conservatoire c'est un partenaire
pour nous en Guadeloupe majeur et joue
le jeu et
un fonctionnement qui est assez
intéressant et puis une discussion des
échanges concernant cela vous allez
poser la question aussi le type
d'agriculture qu'on avait
malheureusement le type familial faut
savoir que là il faut pousser à porter
la mise en place la surface moyenne de
Guadeloupe il y a les petites elle est
petite contrairement à la Micropole ou
même certaines d'hommes
elle était de elle est passée de deux
hectares et demi avec la réforme
foncière à cathéties
de donner des tailles d'exploitation qui
sera qui scanne taille économique
pouvant permettre à mettre en place une
écriture familiale pour que l'exploitant
puisse dégager un revenu et puis
permettre de vivre sa famille que
d'avoir des petites exploitations c'est
vrai que maintenant avec tous les
événements
que créé la guerre le coût des entrant
c'est vrai que ça a un impact assez sa
propre problème plus ça nous commet
à mon avis qu'ici
et les moins important N'oubliez pas les
villes que nous sommes nous sommes très
loin très loin de
la France
la métropole le souci qui se passe c'est
que c'est pour ça qu'on doit faire
vraiment on doit faire attention
particulière forcément pour nous la
population il faut des hommes il faut de
la terre si on compare on regarde plus
pointu qu'ici forcément le jour qui va
une crise majeure majeur on risque entre
parenthèses permettez-moi de covid
alors je dis pourquoi attention
particulière c'est faire attention pour
que là aujourd'hui on est dans une
dynamique c'est vrai la canne la banane
on a depuis des décennies on le dit on
leur dit qu'il faut arriver à
l'opposition alimentaire on a eu des
présidents de la République
successivement qui sont venus qui ont
dit les mêmes choses il faut arriver il
faut arriver le problème c'est que le
temps passe
les choses se mettent à mon avis un peu
trop tardivement plate il faut
rapidement pour que ce foncier à tel
point il a dit tout à l'heure le
directeur de la Martinique il a dit on a
même arrivé à avoir des terrains qui
étaient cultivés par le passé qui sont
devenus en friche et en Guadeloupe on a
le même problème on a pu recenser
environ 10 000 hectares de terrain en
friche
qui nécessite
d'être mise à profit pour le
développement agricole donc là on voit
en tout cas on est nous pour moi des
territoires
qui on a du potentiel il y a du
potentiel il faut conforter protéger le
foncier à d'avoir des outils de
régulation comme les affaires
et quand j'ai une vie de tout à l'heure
qui est quand même un lieu de
confrontation avec l'ensemble des
acteurs
voilà ce que je voulais dire à ce stade
là juste un tout petit point
supplémentaire par rapport à le type
d'agriculture on est allé dans Judée il
y a il y a un mois et on est allé
visiter le une des stations de l'inrae
où il y a justement tout un une
réflexion Rodrigue sur le la
modification et des expérimentations qui
pourraient permettre de d'être dans une
agriculture entre guillemets plus
intensive et plus protectrice de
l'environnement en même temps parce que
et un passage justement à une partie
pour pas complètement passer de
l'économie cannière à autre chose parce
que les usines elles ont besoin d'être
approvisionnées mais là on était sur des
modèles l'Inra a vraiment toute une
réflexion sur comment intégrer le fait
qu'il y aura moins de produits par
rapport à votre question moins de
produits phyto et et
en outre-mer les besoins de protection
sont plus importants encore qu'ailleurs
avec le climat il fait humide et autres
donc on a des et donc avec la réflexion
qui a été qu'on est là où on est allé
visiter cette station de l'INRA il y
avait une réflexion entre l'é levage le
Boyer des complémentarités qui
permettent normalement qui devraient
permettre il devrait permettre à ce qui
est des nouveaux modèles proposés pour
installer des jeunes agriculteurs
est-ce que le changement climatique
permet de faire une autre agriculture
est-ce qu'il y a des produits que vous
ne cultiviez pas à une époque
qu'aujourd'hui peut-être avait le
changement climatique que vous allez
pouvoir faire
c'est vrai que on a en Guadeloupe en
tout cas on a une tendance à revenir sur
les cultures que l'on avait abandonné et
qui ont des qui permettent de
développement non négligeables
aujourd'hui
on vient dessus le café les cultures
qu'on ancestrales et souvent dans la sur
la le côté code sous le vent ok oui il y
a des choses qui qui reviennent et puis
comme disait le président yes
aujourd'hui
il nous faut retrouver le bon modèle de
développement et pour pouvoir optimiser
la petite tête de nos exploitations et
c'est vrai que la saphir a engagé avec
Lina et
cette volonté de permettre de
toutes les petites tailles
d'exploitation de générer un revenu qui
permettrait d'installer le maximum de
jeunes ou de conforter ceux qui sont
déjà installés j'ai mis de préciser
l'élément concernant le PF aujourd'hui
il y a quand même un fait qui qui est
clair selon les statistiques la
population
à notre mère est plus agréablement
Guadeloupe elle est vieillissante elle
diminue donc on pourrait penser que
normalement diminution vieillissement
donc on va consommer moins d'espace donc
ça il faut qu'on l'entende parce que
souvent il faut l'entendre autre chose
importante c'est que on a la chance en
Guadeloupe plus régulièrement d'avoir
une EPF qui a pris l'option et qui est
je veux dire intelligente d'observer ce
qui se passe ce qui se passe c'est que
on a dans les dans les villes plus
régulièrement Pointe-à-Pitre et toutes
les villes d'ailleurs de on a beaucoup
beaucoup de de d'habitation abandonnés
puisque bon abandonner et là l'option le
l'EPF chez nous c'est de problème
d'ailleurs il y a des problèmes de
division
de rack d'acheter
ce foncier là il a donc pour suivre du
bâti pour pouvoir héberger la population
voilà dans les villes en sachant que les
vieillissante et qu'elle diminue donc je
pense que là dessus c'est aussi pour nos
politiques en Guadeloupe une preuve
d'intelligence de d'observer et c'est
vrai que les affaires la chance qu'on a
c'est que on a un véritable on a fait ce
qui se passe au-delà de effectivement de
l'action sur le marché on observe et on
peut se projeter voilà il y a une
problématique qu'il faut pas qu'on
oublie qui est vrai partout c'est la
problématique de l'eau
et quand je dis les problématiques de
l'eau c'est comme partout à la fois
l'eau potable et l'eau agricole
parce que on modifiera pas les modèles
d'agriculture si on n'est pas capable
d'apporter de l'eau un maraîcher il a
besoin d'eau pour pour faire pousser ses
cultures et on le voit par la Réunion la
SAFER a accompagné le passage de l'eau
de la côte sous le vent à l'autre côté
ce qui a permis à développement de
terrain qui était sec et qui aujourd'hui
grâce à l'irrigation son prospère donc
c'est c'est une vraie problématique ou
fâche pas je le dis parce que c'est
souvent un tabou dans notre pays quand
on parle de d'irrigation il y a pas
d'agriculture s'il y a pas d'eau et
l'irrigation c'est pas forcément un
canon qui qui jette de l'eau en l'air ça
peut être aujourd'hui il y a des
nouvelles méthodes d'irrigations avec du
goutte-à-goutte avec tout un tas de
choses comme ça qui qui permettent de
d'économiser l'eau tout en ayant de
l'eau et souvent l'agriculture peut et
même souvent une une composante
de la réserve d'eau potable aussi
il faut il faut qu'on les intègre dans
le raisonnement des équipements et
autres tous ensemble parce que
c'est c'est la même eau en fait en
général
merci de ces précisions on va continuer
nos échanges et deux demandes de prise
de parole victoire jasmin et Annick
Pétrus dans l'ordre et juste avant je
vais être un peu égoïste je m'en excuse
j'ai une j'ai une question présent
puisque vous nous avez quand même mis
sur la piste et je pense que le
législateur sera intéressé de connaître
les pistes auxquelles vous changez pour
consolider les situations financières
des affaires en outre-mer qui sont
visiblement très différentes en termes
de d'espace disponible et peut-être de
volume d'échanges fonciers constater
donc on est très preneur vos
observations et puis j'ai une troisième
prise de parole que je j'inscris dès
maintenant mishtin Jack dans la foulée
donc je laisse la parole à mes collègues
et puis après je vous laisserai le soin
de pouvoir y répondre donc victoire
Annick Micheline et Viviane
et Victor bien évidemment
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci aux différentes
personnes ressources qui sont ici
alors je tiens à remercier le président
Talo mais aussi les collègues qui ont
accepté que nous puissions travailler
sur cette problématique lorsqu'il s'est
agit de décider de la programmation pour
plusieurs raisons parce que bon j'ai
proposé le travail sur ce sujet et je à
travers ce qui vient d'être dit je crois
que nous avons eu collectivement raison
parce que nous parlons tous de
souveraineté alimentaire nous parlons
tous de beaucoup de choses mais le
foncier est important et pour avoir
rencontré à la fois la FNSE affaire que
je remercie parce que j'ai répondu à une
de leurs invitations j'ai participé à
des réunions et après avoir rencontré
évidemment les personnes ont tout ce qui
sont présentes là mais aussi ceux de la
réunion de la Guyane je me suis rendu
compte qu'il était important pour nos
territoires que nous puissions commencer
par cette problématique pour pouvoir
bien comprendre de quoi il s'agit et là
je suis très contente entendu aussi
votre version parce que là c'est dp9 en
fait quand on écoute les élus pour ce
qui concerne la Guadeloupe j'ai souvent
entendu dire le contraire en fait et là
ça permet de recadrer de comprendre
pourquoi vous en tant que parce que nous
nous sommes en fait des reprises entre
les collectivités et c'est important de
bien comprendre les choses là je vois
que contrairement à ce qui se dit du
côté des élus que là c'est des P9 vit
conforme ça ne convient pas mais je ne
comprends mieux pourquoi vous vous
défendez ce foncier agricole d'autant
plus que bon on a eu ces dernières
années à valider des Plans Locaux
urbanisme avec des équilibres
déséquilibres et peut-être des
équilibres je ne sais pas mais par
rapport aux fonciers donc ça ce sont des
problématiques et les élus ont eu à
travailler sur ces problématiques là et
on n'a pas forcément toujours eu la vie
de la SAFER sur sur cela en plus les
petites pensées vous l'avez dit monsieur
le Président Trump que les pensées sur
nos territoires et les pensées agricoles
et là aussi il y a des contraintes
budgétaires pour les affaires à la fois
de bienfait leur travail mais aussi pour
les agriculteurs humaines donc nous
avons la chance en tout cas d'avoir des
lisses agricoles qui forment nous avons
des jeunes qui veulent s'orienter vers
les professionnels agricoles et
malheureusement c'est le foncier qui
manque donc l'intérêt de de ce travail
également c'est aussi de permettre à nos
jeunes de s'impliquer et de travailler
d'avoir un compagnonnage et puis bon
j'ai entendu des aussi quelques
propositions mais de mettre en place des
chantiers d'insertion pour qu'ils
puissent et pour suivre après eux-mêmes
mais avoir quand même l'expérience des
personnes qui sont vieillissantes certes
mais qui ont une expérience donc le
travail doit être fait de façon
coordonnée avec l'ADL avec en fait
l'ensemble des partenaires pour ce qui
concernent nos territoires et je crois
qu'il est urgent que nous puissions
maintenant qu'il y a une réelle volonté
de parler de souveraineté alimentaire
mais de faire vraiment concrètement ce
qu'il y a à faire de que nous puissions
travailler ensemble donc je vous
remercie vraiment pour les réponses que
vous avez lui a donné à mes collègues
mais
je voudrais parler très rapidement
également de la façon d'aménagement j'ai
le territoire vous l'avez évoqué déjà
avec ceux qui se fait mais il y a aussi
des échos quartiers on a des textes
récents issus du Sénat sur les la
nécessité aussi de mettre en place des
mesures pour entre guillemets ne pas
artificialiser complètement les sols
donc on parle de 0 artificialisation
nette de plus en plus parce que nous
voyons évidemment avec les difficultés
et liées également au risque naturel
majeurs comment l'aurait sans surface et
on l'a vu récemment avec la tempête
Fiona sur une partie de notre territoire
nous avons aussi les contraintes
liéeschroniques donc il faudrait aussi
prendre en compte cela mais je crois que
bon valoriser le foncier même quand il
est il est contaminé c'est possible donc
pouvoir évidemment mettre en
compatibilité les cultures qui
pourraient être
compatible avec les
vont se poser face aux différentes la
mesure où il y a beaucoup de fonciers
appartenant à l'État il y a
effectivement une nécessité de remettre
en place les choses pour que en Guyane
également que l'État puisse trouver le
meilleur pour solution possible pour
pour permettre à la SAFER en tout cas de
jouer pleinement son rôle et de tendre
vers l'autonomie alimentaire donc je
vais vraiment donner le sens de ce que
notre collègue tany a dit parce qu'en
fait il a travaillé avant sur le foncier
avec d'autres collègues il y a déjà des
rapports du Sénat mais c'était plus par
rapport à l'habitat il est là la
proposition de notre collègue notre
ancien collègue parlementaire les chimie
c'est un compte également des travaux
qui ont été menés il y a quelques années
et déjà ici donc l'extension on ne peut
pas constituer sur l'extension
urbain mais travailler davantage pour
nos territoires respectifs pour que
l'agriculture soit quand même
le centre tout en maintenant une
certaine diversification parce qu'on
peut pas
qui ne peut pas pour se poursuivre alors
qu'en même temps on a des jeunes des
jeunes qui sont en situation de chômage
donc là les réponses à apporter sont
celles de l'inclusion de l'inclusion
mais de l'accompagnement également parce
que très souvent on a l'impression que
les jeunes ne veulent pas travailler
mais non mais c'est parce qu'ils n'ont
pas suffisamment de personnes ressources
autour pour les encadrer pour les aider
à mieux appréhender
ces problématiques là et de prendre en
compte justement la possibilité de
développer le pays là donc ils ont
discuté il y a pas longtemps avec
Monsieur Catherine a fait lorsqu'on doit
on s'est rencontré on a eu un certain
nombre de pistes et je suis vraiment
très heureuse aujourd'hui que grâce aux
travaux que nous avons initié en fait
avant que nous puissions aujourd'hui se
retrouver ici
avec les collègues non représentons les
territoires et je pense que c'est grâce
aux travaux que nous allons faire que
nous allons inverser la tendance pour
permettre à nos territoire de se
développer au niveau économique et au
niveau agricole et pour la souveraineté
alimentaire il faut pas partir de cela
merci beaucoup et merci à tous les
collègues une fois de plus
bonjour à tous merci président de me
donner la parole alors on l'a tous
compris et on ne va pas démontrer
l'importance de ce sujet dans nos
travaux
nous les territoires ultramarins nous
avons une réelle problématique pour ce
qui est de des surfaces agricoles qui
seraient disponible
et qui nous permettrait de survivre si
demain il arrivait quelque chose alors
je me présente et vous comprendrez
pourquoi je suis Annick Pétrus donc la
sénatrice de la collectivité
territoriale de Saint-Martin
petit territoire de 53 km2
avec oui une double insularité et vous
venez d'annoncer que effectivement un
contrat a été signé avec la collectivité
dans le cadre justement de la protection
des terres agricoles
je me réjouis de cette démarche
je n'ai pas encore pris connaissance de
tous les termes du contrat et ma
question serait celle-là est-ce qu'il
est prévu dans ce contrat
à un moment un accompagnement
de la collectivité vers ses premiers pas
de la vers l'agriculture parce que
justement c'est créé très peu développé
chez nous au moment où je parle donc
sécuriser le foncier oui
puisque s'enfoncer rien n'est possible
est-ce que il y a aussi de prévu
un moyen de pour que ces premiers pas je
me répète vers l'agriculture se fasse
alors quand je dis un accompagnement il
peut être de tout autre voilà
quelle était ma question
Micheline Jacques et ensuite Viviane
Artigalas et puis je vous laisserai
semaine de pouvoir apporter les éléments
réponse le président merci pour vos
interventions très éclairantes ma
question sera plus d'ordre
institutionnel sachant que dans les
territoires régis par l'article 73 les
textes législatifs s'appliquent de plein
droit j'aurais aimé savoir est-ce que
vous êtes consulté lors de l'élaboration
de textes ou de révision de certains
textes relatifs offensiers je pense
comme l'a dit victoire à la zéro
artificialisation nette à la loi SRU en
fait toutes ces lois qui émanent
d'ici et savoir est-ce qu'elles sont
aussi adaptées au territoire où est-ce
qu'il faudrait par territoire puisque
chaque territoire a des spécificités et
des réalités
pareil avoir des des dispositions
spécifiques pour chaque territoire ultra
marin de manière à pérenniser et même à
consolider l'autosuffisance alimentaire
puisque d'un côté vous avez des
populations des besoins en logement qui
sont énormes
pour avoir travaillé sur le logement
notamment le logement social outre-mer
vous avez aussi la nécessité d'aller
vers l'autosuffisance alimentaire et
parallèlement la zéro artificialisme
donc comment on arrive à articuler tout
ça sur des territoires comme vous l'avez
dit ou l'espace est très contraint et
les tensions sont exacerbées
le tourisme fait aussi monter le coup du
foncier et donc il n'avait pas les
moyens de racheter des des granges ou
des bâtiments à des propriétés agricoles
et est-ce que vous avez vous aussi dans
vos territoires ces conflits entre le
tourisme et le sur les questions de
fonciers entre le développement
d'infrastructures de tourisme et le
développement ou le maintien d'activités
agricoles ou est-ce qu'à l'occasion de
effectivement de vente de vente le
tourisme l'emporte sur l'agriculture et
est-ce que vous arrivez à travailler
vous en avez un petit peu parlé au début
ça vous concerne peut-être un peu moins
mais c'est quand même important sur ces
questions d'agritourisme parce que ma
deuxième question va aussi sur le revenu
des agriculteurs on voit bien aussi on a
ces mêmes problèmes en France
actuellement en métropole actuellement
mais partout sur le territoire sur en
année à la troisième loi égalithme pour
essayer d'améliorer le revenu des
agriculteurs et c'est là que la question
parce que ils vont bien évidemment et
c'est logique vers des
de l'activité qui leur rapportent nous
on avait réussi effectivement en
territoire de montagne à faire du double
comment dire de la double activité
agricole et complémentarité avec des
activités touristiques autour
effectivement de de l'accompagnement des
randonnées de visite à l'affaire de
choses comme ça et voilà donc c'est
plutôt sur les questions du lien entre
tourisme et agriculture ou de des
conflits entre-tourisme et agriculture
et la dernière chose vous parlez d'une
d'une activité plutôt familiale mais
quand même très par exemple en
Guadeloupe le basé sur la canne et sur
la canne à sucre et la banane est-ce
qu'il y a une ces possibilités de
diversification qui continuent quand
même à maintenir un niveau suffisant de
revenus pour les agriculteurs parce que
c'est ça qui est en jeu aussi et est-ce
que par exemple on vous voyait comment
on voit dans d'autres dans d'autres
territoires pas forcément arriver des
grandes sociétés qui essaient de capter
du foncier comme ça peut se passer c'est
un petit peu la loi ça passe tous qui
voulait lutter contre cette accaparation
du foncier par des grandes sociétés je
vois que le groupement foncier agricole
de Guadeloupe peut permettre de d'être
une alternative à ce genre de captation
de foncier
sur les parties générales et puis bien
évidemment je laisserai mes collègues
parce qu'ils ont il y a beaucoup de
questions où moi j'ai pas la réponse
je pense qu'il y a une une partie de
réponse sur qu'on parlait tout à l'heure
madame la sénatrice sur
l'adaptation il je pense qu'il faut
qu'on modifie la fiscalité locale la
pression sur les terres agricoles elles
sont elle est souvent liée et on l'a
entendu à des élus locaux qui n'ont
comme seul ressources pour augmenter
leur capacité financière moi je suis je
suis aussi élu je suis majeur dans une
commune alors il y a 12000 habitants
d'un petit peu plus gros mais mais bon
malgré tout
la seule ressource on construit une
maison pour avoir une fiscalité
supplémentaire et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on sorte de ce
schéma dans dans les communes rurales si
on veut un moment donné qui est moins de
pression il faut il faut trouver une
autre assise que uniquement la six
foncière pour qu'il y ait des ressources
sur les communes rurales et je pense que
la pression des élus locaux sur Lausanne
sera moins importante
j'en suis convaincu ensuite il faut
il faut absolument qu'on accompagne
l’ingénierie dans les collectivités
locales rurales parce que protéger le
terrain agricole faire un urbanisme de
meilleure qualité ça nécessite de
l'accompagnement et ça aujourd'hui il y
a beaucoup de collectivités qui l'ont
pas et donc si on veut accompagner parce
que on parlait tout à l'heure de
récupérer des dents creuses de faire des
choses comme ça ça nécessite de la
réflexion ça décide du financement
des financements croisés les et donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
imagine un nouveau modèle les scottes
sont un point importants qui est de la
cohérence sur le territoire je peux vous
assurer que
par expérience vous définissez quelque
chose à jour les EPCI modifient leur
périmètre et puis peuvent vous vous
retrouvez que vous avez plus de Scott
par exemple bon et donc la cohérence que
vous aviez imaginé un jour elle n'est
plus vrai demain il faut se projeter
dans du temps long si on veut protéger
le foncier AG ricole et avoir un
développement équilibré on peut pas vous
mettre un coup à goût à coup d'un côté à
coup de l'autre ça marche pas ça c'est
on est vraiment sur de du temps long je
pense que ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important alors
pour répondre à la question très précise
sur Saint-Martin donc on a fini hier en
fait on vient faire un diagnostic là
c'est ce que je vous dis l'objet c'est
vraiment de d'être capable avec une
vision extérieure de faire un diagnostic
du territoire pour voir quelle solution
en fonction des demandes que la
collectivité aura puisqu'on a signé avec
le président de la collectivité à
monsieur je suis sur le Wellington je
crois voilà donc c'est vraiment l'objet
de faire un un point et après on
proposera des solutions en fonction de
ce qu'on nous demandera et là c'est
vraiment un point pour
et puis nous les affaires pour que les
choses soient bien bien précises on fait
tout ce qui concerne les diagnostics sur
le foncier quand on est sur des
développe des diagnostics de
développement agricole on passe la main
aux champs d'agriculture ou autre parce
que c'est c'est notre mission elle est
sur la problématique foncière et on
travaille avec les Chambres
d'agriculture en complémentarité sur
tous les sujets de développement
agricole ou autre voilà sur les
questions plus générales je crois moi
que j'ai jamais répondu et puis je vais
passer la parole à Rodrigue et à Robert
Catherine Robert Catherine qui vous
présentera le ce qu'on propose pour
financer les affaires des territoires
d'outre-mer
je vais donc je vais répondre
appuyer la réponse que tu as apporté à
madame la sénatrice il est vrai que
l'opération qui va se tenir
dès le jour qui viennent parce qu'on va
commencer à faire le diagnostic l'état
des lieux de toutes les parcelles
agricoles au plus de la commune de la de
la communauté de Saint-Martin on va
faire un point il s'agit là pour nous de
regarder la valeur agronomique en détail
et comme ça pour que la collectivité
puisse mieux se projeter sur les
potentialités agricoles qui est là sous
son territoire et après il s'agira pour
nous dans un premier temps cette
première phase et deuxième temps lui
accompagner au mieux que l'on puisse il
est vrai que le président a été très
sensible à la problématique de
d'arriver à avoir une meilleure tout le
couvertures au cas où hein
mais je crois que c'est il faut quand
même souligner et féliciter le Président
Washington d'avoir vu la nécessité déjà
de faire un étaler le Précis parce que
je crois que selon ce qu'il nous a dit
ça n'avait jamais été fait par le passé
mais en fait un travail de qualité où on
pourra exactement savoir la
classification du foncier les qualités
ergonomiques enfin travail assez pointu
là-dessus pour pour répondre après à
Madame concernant le concernant la
problématique des conflits d'usage qui
pourrait avoir avec le tourisme et
l'agriculture la chance qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est que les terres
agricoles en tout cas en Guadeloupe
c'est essentiellement
d'analytère donc on a très peu on a un
Guadeloupe très peu de conflits d'usage
entre la seule chose qu'on qu'on a pu
connaître bon et c'est vrai que NAF
aussi
à agi le sens où on avait bon tous ceux
qui à gros tourisme
les constructions de gîte ou autre tous
les espaces agricoles
le la doctrine de la CD Bénin c'est si
ça peut accompagner un couple revenu
point agriculteur on autorise les
constructions par contre si c'est si ça
doit on doit continuer à consommer des
Ferrari
pour culture qui est pas de complément
de revenu là a tendance à refuser la
construction de voilà parce que
autrement vous imaginez sous une île
comme la nôtre bon tout le monde voulait
avoir voilà pouvoir construire et
parfois en détournant la problématique
gîte j'ai tout autre donc ça là-dessus
on arrive à contenir
concernant je crois que c'est pas porte
aux jeunes on a posé la question
peut-être les jeunes il est vrai il est
vrai que le souci premier aujourd'hui de
la de la Guadeloupe c'est de permettre
d'accompagner au mieux une transition
entre la génération actuelle
et la génération future parce que il est
clair on a dit il faut le foncier pour
répondre à l'autosuffisance alimentaire
mais il faut surtout les hommes les
hommes formés et les hommes qui ont la
volonté et on sait très bien le taux de
chômage qui puisse exister chez nous on
a quand même la chance d'avoir les
outils comme le
et on a eu l'occasion il y a quelques
années le recensé à peu près de diplômés
en capacité de gérer l'exploitation on a
ressenti un peu pour un peu moins de 400
jeunes qui ont la formation agricole
maintenant c'est l'oxygène ils attendent
pas ils font peut-être autre chose mais
maintenant les les organes agricoles que
nous nous gérons on doit maintenant
rapidement faire en sorte que on puisse
permettre à ces jeunes de rentrer dans
le tissu agricole tout en tout au long
assurant vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
revenu je crois que c'est là la
problématique le revenu et c'est vrai
que là chez nous plus qui plus que plus
que en hexagone l'état quand même doit
apporter un appui non négligeable parce
que vous connaissez un petit peu le
sous-cou que que ça depuis toujours
localement ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
avec un environnement
caribéen ou voilà où on a pu avoir une
concurrence un petit peu différente
parce qu'on a des soucoupes liés à notre
niveau de vie aussi voilà
alors
sur la proposition de financement des
affaires
à l'origine
en 1960 quand on a créé les affaires
elles étaient bénéficiaient d'un
financement public de l'État
à cette époque là l'État a été riche
aujourd'hui c'est moi le cas donc au fil
de au fil des années on a vu la dotation
la dotation publique
allait en diminution en diminution et
comme vous l'a dit le président Yester
des dômes bénéficie d'un corps d'un
petit volet mais qui n'est pas suffisant
pour le fonctionnement des des quatre
saphirds
nous avons proposé des jeunes à l'époque
il y a 5 ans
on avait proposé à l'image des EPF
d'avoir un financement qui serait une
taxe de
une taxe de
infecté de 2 euros par habitant
malheureusement ça n'a pas été validé
donc nous revenons aujourd'hui
avec une proposition un peu similaire
mais aussi on s'est rendu compte je
reprends le cas de la Martinique qui est
celui que je connais le mieux
on a en moyenne 500 notifications par an
c'est 500 notifications par an avoisine
les 45 millions d'euros en termes de
value
est-ce qu'il y a pas un moyen
notre réflexion on n'a pas on n'a pas
encore abouti est-ce qu'il y a pas un
moyen de capter une part un film de ces
45 millions d'euros qui permettrait de
ne plus solliciter les collectivités et
l'État
et de faire reposer la perception de cet
axe que par le vendeur et la théorie ou
la théorie ça c'est à déterminer aussi
et donc
on s'imaginait que un
pour cent un à 2 % de cette de cette
valeur permettrait de où s'affair de de
pouvoir fonctionner sans que ça pèse sur
la collectivité on sait bien que les
collectivités en budget restreint et que
il y a un moment où elles pourront
peut-être pas suivre le financement là
ça fait à Martinique par exemple elle
bénéficie de financement de 500.000
euros par an
depuis déjà de nombreuses années mais
chaque année on ne sait pas si on va
avoir un financement et quand on l'aura
c'est surtout ça la difficulté de
gestion et donc
là on
dépendrait plus de la collectivité
ce qui en termes de dépendance serait
une chose de qualité parce que la saphir
ne doit être dépendante d'aucune
structure
elle est indépendante mais elle est
toujours il faut toujours rappeler que
la safe est toujours sur le contrôle de
l'État puisque siège en son sein du
commissaire du gouvernement qui ont le
droit de veto sur toutes les décisions
que les affaires prend donc la Safia
n'est pas libre de faire n'importe quoi
toutes ces décisions sont contrôlées par
l'État
je pense que c'est une c'est une option
dans laquelle il faudrait peut-être
sourire TV à laquelle il faudrait
s'orienter c'est la seule
qui a qui a je me répète je vais me
répéter qu'il y a l'avantage de ne peser
sur
aucun financement public
et juste si on parce qu'en fait on ça ça
fonctionne bien chez vous où il y a une
valeur par rapport au délia qui est
importante il y a des territoires où ça
pourrait pas être le cas donc on a il y
a deux il y a ces deux options il y a
celle là et la première qui est la plus
simple en fait à mettre en œuvre qui est
équivalent au financement des EPF
aujourd'hui ça serait à l'intérieur de
l'enveloppe des EPF qui est une partie
qui soit affectée au financement des
affaires des territoires d'outre-mer et
avec un plafond à 2 euros puisqu'on a
déjà regardé les besoins avec un plafond
à 2 euros on est largement dans ça
répondrait aux besoins du financement et
ça éviterait que tous les ans les
responsables des affaires aille comme
Robert Catherine l'a dit toqué aux
portes de la collectivité c'est c'est
des contraintes c'est agréable pour
personne et ça pèse sur les finances des
collectivités territoriales alors que
c'est pas logique en fait là on est
vraiment dans un la mise en oeuvre d'une
mission de service public qui devrait
être financé
comme toute service public
victorinurel vous voulez intervenir
monsieur le Président merci à vous
d'être là et pour vos
précieuses informations
alors pour la bonne forme je dis à mes
collègues quelque part je suis victime
de conflits d'intérêt puisque dans une
vie antérieure ma jeunesse mais aussi
ma profession j'ai été directeur de
chambre et j'ai créé le premier GFA sur
les 38 et quelques GFA qui existent
aujourd'hui un Guadeloupe c'est quelque
chose donc j'ai vécu et j'ai même risqué
ma vie lorsqu'on m'a mis un fusil sur
les tempes pour me dire on va pas créer
le premier GFA c'était là ça fait qui
était à l'époque responsable de ça mais
il y a eu à l'époque avec un directeur
que je n'aurais pas ici une incapacité à
le faire donc on avait un peu confié au
directeur que j'étais sous l'autorité
d'un brésident d'un conseil le soin de
faire démarrer la réforme foncière on
l'a fait ça existe toujours alors
j'espère messieurs que vous n'allez pas
mal vivre ce que je vais vous dire mes
collègues me connaissent
j'aime poser des questions de manière un
peu franche la première question que je
vous poserai c'est sûr pardonnez-moi
l'utilité des affaires aujourd'hui
sont-ils encore vraiment utiles en face
des EPF
il y avait à l'époque des intentions du
Gouvernement de dire il faut mutualiser
ça avec une taxe de 20 euros par
habitant pour les EPF faut-il pour
assurer l'indépendance de sa faire une
taxe de même nature tu n'as pas abouti
et aujourd'hui on a bien l'impression et
vous l'avez dit clairement on a
l'impression que quelque part on a créé
une dépendance et ça fait à l'égard
notamment des collectivités locales ce
qui veut dire que dans des petits
territoires ça peut donner tout sur
l'indépendance sur les préemptions sur
les notifications sur les moyens pour
faire le job et très souvent vous n'avez
pas les moyens de votre intervention si
je regarde votre dossier ce que nous
avait remis monsieur le Président nous a
parlé de faire des affaires des
instruments de régulation du prix du
foncier je prends vos propres chiffres
vous avez eu
1104 notifications en 2019
ça a baissé depuis le je prends pas
depuis 2012 puisque vous donnez les
chiffres
et président trèfle c'est la Guadeloupe
727 vous notez que 14 fois
vous aviez un prix à les moyens hectare
je prends le pic de 2018 le prix à
l'hectare valait 238000 euros
aujourd'hui il vaut encore
141642 euros
sur le marché et je sais pas si on peut
l'appeler au marché foncier très
restreint le marché très restreint
est-ce que vous réglez les prix avec 14
préemptions sur un millier de moyenne
entre
1100 et 700 disons à peu près 850 vous
pouvez en Décathlon soit avec quel moyen
et combien de fois effectivement vous
avez pris un té sur les 14 avez-vous les
moyens de payer
j'aimerais que vous nous disiez dans
l'effectivité ce qui
se fait vraiment ensuite sur
la nature même juridique des saveurs
combien de SA faire ont des présidents
ou d'autres formes et comment ça se
passe le président très français quelque
chose il dit rapports qui ont défrayé
les chroniques en Guadeloupe en disant
que c'est mal géré et que ça remplit pas
ses objectifs vous voyez donc j'espère
que ça choque pas le président très fin
il n'y a rien de personnel mais se
posait le problème de l'utilité de la
mutualisation de leur efficacité et de
leur coût faut-il aujourd'hui pour
réguler le foncier qui est ce type
d'instrument où faut-il aller plus loin
ou faut-il donner des moyens et comment
on ne fait que 14 installations à
Guadeloupe alors vous avez un Guadeloupe
résumant
160 000 hectares de terre c'est la
Guadeloupe 1600 km² à peu près
j'arrondis vous avez 32000 hectares sur
ça vous avez 7200 et quelques
agriculteurs
et quand on regarde sur les perspectives
vous avez un PPAS
d'ici 20 ans
mais je pense que c'est une réalité en
terme de compétitivité etc c'est un
sujet la canne ça va durer plus
longtemps bon peut-être aujourd'hui quel
est le bilan de la référence en Syrie il
y en a eu trois la dernière et peut-être
la plus connue ou en tequelle celle dont
on se souvient 12000 hectares de terre
achetés par l'État à l'époque
gouvernement Moha ça s'appelle le plan
Moura on a distribué
le reste il en restait à peu près 4000
il reste aujourd'hui quoi 2000 c'est ça
ou
que fait-on je vois qu'il y a des choses
innovantes on envoie est-ce que on en
vend pour l'artificialisation
apparemment oui à quel prix mais du coup
c'est vallonné c'est une typographie
chahuter un relief difficile mais est-ce
que c'est un régulateur pour justement
poser sur le les prix non pas seulement
par le facteur prix mais le fait que
vous ayez un stock permettrait peut-être
de réguler et le prix du foncier est
peut-être le prix de l'urbanisable
ensuite c'est beaucoup de questions mais
entre la loi et ses ruche
et le CD B9 quel est l'articulation
parce que moi on a connu en Guadeloupe
mais j'imagine en Martinique dans la
Réunion c'est la même chose vous avez un
minimum de
terrain aménagé à faire pour avoir des
logements sociaux et donc quand vous
n'arrivez pas à obtenir cet objectif
vous payez des vous êtes sanctionnés en
fait vous payez une sorte de taxe petit
canal a connu ça c'est François a connu
ça beaucoup de communes en Guadeloupe
ils ont une surface agricole dite utile
les voitures de 32000 après le 14000 qui
sont en friche ils ont une surface
agricole d'outil ils peuvent plus
déclasser en vertu des plus devenu des
postes venus plus donc contraire par
cette législation mais en même temps
obligé par le SRU à avoir des terres
urbanisées or le CD P9 et moi j'ai voté
ça à l'époque je l'avoue ses débuts non
c'est un conforme ici dans l'Hexagone
c'est un avis simple donc je décideur ne
sont pas obligés d'en tenir compte mais
là-bas c'est un avis confort comment ça
s'articule comment vivez-vous ça vous
cette contradiction entre les
obligations des collectivités de mettre
des terrains aménagé à disposition pour
la construction des logements sociaux et
en même temps la l'objectif de préserver
autant que possible le foncier
de bonne valeur agronomique et le
foncier
utile comment vivez-vous ça
en
Guadeloupe ensuite sur les la réforme
foncière elle-même 60% possédée par la
Société des parents foncières agricoles
de la Guadeloupe ça dirait peut-être
quelque chose après à nous collègues et
40% par Ligier enfin où en est-on
aujourd'hui il y a près de 10 millions
de créances impayés
votre dossier mais c'est plus que ça
ensuite les agriculteurs ou les 8000
hectares qui ont été distribués en GFA
un GF face à fait à peu près 150
hectares
c'est une collectivité et c'est très
bien c'était une belle réflexion de
l'époque que nous avions tous faites de
dire il faut pas rétrocider un
propriétaire individuelles on a une
propriété collective à peu près 150
hectares on met 10 15 personnes c'est
entre 10 et 15 hectares la surface
moyenne possédée par chaque agriculteur
chaque agriculteur devait faire pour
préserver la CAN 60% Cannes et 40%
diversification végétales et animales
bon ou en étant aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
moi j'ai vu des GFA j'ai été interrogé
beaucoup d'agriculteurs ne payent pas
leur loyer
deuxièmement l'exploitent plus
troisièmement sous l'eau allez ils sont
pas propriétaire mais ils sont exploités
avec un type d'exploitation c'est à dire
qu'il prend du temps à être formalisé
très officiellement mais sous l'eau et
sous l'eau à des travailleurs étrangers
qui eux travaillent pour être clair
aux Haïtiens
aujourd'hui on se demande est-ce qu'il
ne faut pas repenser cette réforme
foncière est-ce que les affaires ont les
moyens de repenser ça je dis ça pour que
on soit dans la vérité pour que nous
sachions quelle est l'avenir de cette
agriculture là à mon sens il faudrait
avoir le cours et ce sera pas simple je
l'avoue de faire une mise en place de
voir comment reprendre comment on
s'acquitte de ça pour que tout ça de
dégringole pas et ne soit pas en
faillite je dis la même chose pour le PF
le BF c'est moi qui l'ai écrit en tant
que président de chambre à l'époque avec
une dotation un dispositif d'amorçage
pour commencer aujourd'hui le PF
intervient partout sur le 32 communes de
la Guadeloupe mais même avec les 20
euros je vous dis tôt ou tard ça aura
des difficultés financières on fait du
portail foncier sur cinq ans et ben 50
contenus des difficultés des
collectivités les collectivités ne
peuvent pas rembourser donc aujourd'hui
il y aura un tel ou telle tension sur la
très honorerie de l'EPF le PF qui s'est
un peu substitué à vous faute de moyen
et forte d’articulation et bien si on
fait pas à terme je dis dans les 5 en 10
ans le PFE de Guadeloupe aura de très
grave problème précisément à cause de
son succès mais précisément aussi parce
qu'il y a pas d'anticipation sur
l'avenir en voilà je m'arrête là parce
qu'il y aurait bien d'autres questions
sur l'orientation agricole sur les plus
les poches sur l'agence urbanisme qui
n'existe pas dans les collectivités sur
le temps qu'on vous fait une seule
modification et pour je les le foncier
ensuite et je finis par de moi je suis
déjà beaucoup trop long pardonnez-moi
mais tous nous parlons
d'autosuffisance alimentaire à mon sens
il faut oublier ça pour être réaliste
parlons d'une certaine autonomie
alimentaire et là on voit la difficulté
l'État a fixer le 0 à artificialisation
des sols pour d'ici 2030 je crois 30 ou
50 30 dans cet état on n'avait jamais
obtenu ça pour être clair donc il faut
repenser tout ça de manière très PRAG
logique il faut repenser les outils il
faut revoir la cdp9 parce que très
souvent ce sont des agriculteurs
eux-mêmes qui demandent de voir
déclasser leur terre pour leurs enfants
ou faire de la spéculation qui demandent
au maire de déclasser leur terrain
d'autant plus qu'on avait le principe de
nous compensation que le Conseil d'État
nous a imposé dans le sable c'est un
praticable voilà je m'arrête là mais on
aura l'occasion peut-être avant le
rapport de d'un discuter de manière plus
approfondie donc une batterie de
questions sur la régulation la gestion
l'avenir les moyens pour que les
affaires restent un outil utile au
service d'une politique agricole
comment on dit ça avec
une familiale à deux UTH comme on disait
à l'époque aujourd'hui j'ai bien
derrière nous ça voilà merci alors
monsieur le sénateur moi je vais
répondre sur une partie où qui est plus
plus généraliste et puis je laisserai
évidemment mes collègues qui connaissent
mieux les territoires je pense que la la
fin de votre propos démontre tout
l'intérêt de la CdP c'est que justement
c'est pas parce qu'on a des intérêts
particuliers
qu'il faut laisser faire il y a une
pression forte et on est vous êtes sur
les territoires
ultramarins l'endroit où il y a le plus
d'écart entre le prix du foncier
agricole et le prix quand il est changé
de destination ça va de 1 à 800 sur les
territoires ultramarins donc vous
imaginez vous avez un terrain qui est
zoné agricole il vaut 1 vous le changez
de destination par une décision de la
collectivité locale il vaut 800 donc
vous imaginez qu'il y a une pression et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut encore plus que
jamais je le dis sur le territoire
national mais à fortiori dans des
territoires contraints encore plus
protéger le foncier agricole ça c'est
vraiment un enjeu majeur sur les les
complémentarités qu'il doit et qu'il y a
je pense entre les EPF et les affaires
il y a eu une époque où il y avait
limite des conflits je me souviens très
bien moi j'étais élu président de la fin
de safer ça fait plus de 12 ans à ce
moment là il y avait même il était
presque imaginé que les affaires
auraient pu passer sous la coupe des EPF
partout sur le territoire national
et
heureusement ça c'est pas fait et je
vais vous dire pourquoi ça s'est pas
fait c'est que on a la chance en France
d'avoir cet outil avec cette spécificité
agricole qui malgré tout est au service
vraiment de l'intérêt général et dans le
monde c'est pas en France dans le monde
70% des contentieux sont liés aux
fonciers attendez bien 70% des
contentieux dans le monde sont autour du
foncier et dans beaucoup d'endroits et
malheureusement l'actualité c'est le cas
aujourd'hui ça se transforme ces
contentieux en conflit
en France depuis maintenant un peu plus
de 60 ans les affaires sont en place je
le disais tout à l'heure globalement à
de très rares exceptions près il y a
plus de contentieux autour du foncier et
pourquoi il y en a plus parce que le
monde agricole les collectivités ont
compris qu'il y avait un véritable enjeu
avec SFR qui regarde le territoire avec
ce prisme agricole
ça veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas l'intérêt
général mais on le regarde avec le
prisme agricole et ça je peux vous
assurer monsieur le sénateur que un EPF
n'aura pas la même capacité à le faire
parce que son rôle et c'est la loi qui
lui demande c'est de dégager des
terrains pour faire de l'urbanisme
et c'est tout à fait légitime je le
conteste pas au contraire je en tant
qu'élu local on utiliser régulièrement
et on fait porter par notre PF ne dormez
des terrains donc ou des ou des
propriétés donc c'est mais ça c'est
vraiment la différence majeure et sur
lesquels je pense que il faut vraiment
qu'on soit vigilant et par contre on
travaille en complémentarité à l'époque
que ça s'est fait Cécile Duflot et on a
écrit dans la loi complémentarité entre
les EPF et les affaires et je peux vous
assurer que on a des conventions
pratiquement partout des conventions
tripartite souvent entre les EPF les
régions et les affaires
et ça permet d'avoir des opérations là
où là où les EPF ont plus de moyens
parce que c'est le cas que les affaires
et qui a besoin de financement les EPF
accompagnent sur des réserves foncières
qui peuvent avoir des enjeux mixtes
accompagnent et sa ferme donc là
vraiment je pense que ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut absolument qu'on
maintienne et par contre et après je
laisse la parole à mes collègues sur la
réforme foncière de la Guadeloupe
Président je me suis le sénateur je
pour avoir suivi pour avoir vraiment
suivi
souvent les discussions je pense qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un courage politique
de façon je l'affirme devant tout ici et
je sais que c'est enregistré il faut
qu'il y a un courage politique pour que
les gens qui ne paient pas leur loyer
soient contraint à le faire on est vous
avez une réforme vous avez vous êtes en
train de faire un rapport il y a besoin
de mettre des jeunes agriculteurs je
trouve que c'est intolérable que des
gens sous loups qu'on ne fasse pas
appliquer la loi la loi c'est le statut
du fermage le statut du fermage dit que
quand on sous loup on perd son bail
rural et en contrepartie on installera
des jeunes agriculteurs moi je peux vous
je le dis et Rodrigue le sait je l'ai je
le dis régulièrement la loi on
l'applique partout sur le territoire
national et là en l'occurrence la loi
n'est pas appliquée donc il faut le
faire parce que il y a un véritable
enjeu là de développement c'est même une
spécificité de la Guadeloupe parce que
il y a eu aussi des GFA qui ont été mis
en place en à la Réunion et globalement
à la Réunion les contraintes sont les
mêmes
et les agriculteurs paient leur loyer
président
parce que j'ai lu dans votre rapport que
vous avez une nouvelle orientation sur
les GFA de vendre en pleine propriété
autant c'est vrai qu'il y a un problème
de comportement et de responsabilité les
gens ne payent pas ensuite on laisse
faire et c'est une vraie dérive mais de
là à petit à petit entamer la propriété
collective la remplacer plein de bruit
et individuel les deux premières
réformes on a vu ça finit en
urbanisation il y a là des contraintes à
maintenir le caractère collectif mais en
même temps avoir une gestion efficace et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vais
vous poser la question Quels sont
peut-être en lien quels sont les types
de gouvernance des affaires le président
13 c'est un président y a-t-il des PDG
quels sont les moyens qui leur sont à
lui vous avez déjà répondu sur les
dotations et quels sont les moyens qu'on
leur donne pour intervenir sur le
foncier le nombre de conseillers etc bon
voilà alors on est on est on est le
statut des affaires société anonyme à
but non lucratif
donc on est PDG mais moi vous m'avez
jamais entendu je me présente toujours
comme président et pas comme PDG parce
que c'est pas mais c'est pas mon c'est
pas mon argent et je voilà même si
juridiquement parlant effectivement tous
les présidents de se faire sont des
mandats sociaux et et on est responsable
y compris sur nos biens propres s'il se
passait quelque chose bon on l'assume ça
me dérange pas moi j'ai mais voilà donc
par contre il faut effectivement que les
affaires et les moyens de le faire et
c'est pour ça que le un financement
pérenne il y a pas que les moyens
financiers mais les moyens financiers
participent à avoir des moyens humains
ou autres de le mettre en oeuvre mais la
limite il y a des limites partout et
c'est heureux les affaires elles n'ont
pas les moyens de police elles n'ont pas
tout ça donc elles peuvent alerter elles
peuvent mettre en avant mais à un moment
donné il faut que soit les responsables
politiques soit la justice
dise on fait payer parce que je suis
d'accord qu'à partir du moment où il y a
de il y a eu de l'argent public il y a
un enjeu de développement local fort et
que il y a des gens qui profitent aux
vrais sens du terme mauvais et du terme
profite de ce système pour avoir des
revenus qui ne leur sont pas normalement
c'est pas pour eux
ça marche à la Réunion donc voilà je
mais je pense qu'il faudra le faire
parce que c'est un véritable enjeu pour
le développement moi aussi enfin si ce
sujet là ne ressortait pas je pense
qu'il y aurait un manque dans le rapport
parce que c'est je vous dis c'est pas et
c'est pas c'est pas endémique sur tous
les territoires c'est vraiment propre là
à la Guadeloupe
propre à la Guadeloupe je le dis c'est
bon Rodrigue je te laisse sur un certain
nombre de points parce que
le sénateur connait très bien la
problématique de Guadeloupe et
en partie alors la première des choses
avec beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites alors première chose concernant
les préemptions alors là ça fait agit en
Guadeloupe essentiellement
malheureusement puisque on l'a dit tout
à l'heure
dit aussi
l'hectare plus de 200000 euros il y a
quelques années maintenant le fait que
là ça fait agi pour réguler le prix le
prix commence à diminuer comment ça
diminué par contre les les façons de
faire interventions de préemption avec
révision de prix c'est-à-dire le prix
qui a été notifié là ça fait il était
trop élevé là ça fait radis j'achète à
tel prix la loi catégorise celui qui est
vendeur enlever le bien de la vente il a
six mois pour le faire malheureusement
c'est ce qu'il fait parce que s'il a
voulu spéculer c'est qu'il fait les 14
options simples c'est à dire on est
d'accord sur le prix et la chose on a
malheureusement une tendance une
tendance aujourd'hui on est obligé
d'aller vers les instances devant les
tribunaux pour oublier le notaire à
faire l'acte parce que c'est vrai que
tous nos territoire il se passe deux
choses déplorables puisque le foncier
pour certains ces sources de richesse
selon normalement
puisque j'explique puisque pourquoi
parce que souvent et là je rebondiais la
fête des p-9 celui qui a acheté des
terres agricoles il avait la certitude
il pouvait faire sa grosse ville avec sa
piscine personne ne lui dit rien y
compris le premier responsable de la
police d'humanisme le maire la problème
ça on a ce problème là aux Antilles
enfin en tout cas Guadeloupe donc là la
cdp9 heureusement permet de piscine
comme ça si vous n'êtes pas agriculteur
piscine agriculteur non il y en a pas
vraiment mais plus de piscine
très bien
pensez au micro pensez au micro parce
que c'est enregistré
alors très bien le sénateur duquel a
raison mais chez nous on a la chance
pour pouvoir justifier premier barrage
justifié le dépôt de permis de agricole
il faut déjà être agriculteur avant de
déclaration de justifier que l'activité
agricole que vous vouliez que vous que
vous faites justifiez que vous habitiez
sur l'exploitation vous voyez là c'est
le bar c'est le barrage essentiel et ça
marche fortement ça c'est une première
chose donc j'ai répondu pour l'aspect
alors concernant la réforme foncière
effectivement le signature dualité
directeur quand ça s'est mis en place
donc il connaît
l'erreur entre parenthèses qu'on a qu'on
a pu faire à l'époque on a donné la
gestion la gérance DGF à
disposition et on supporte le poids de
ce foncier jusqu'à maintenant j'ai enfin
voulu
à l'époque et jusqu'à maintenant on
porte des parts sociales pourquoi pour
deux raisons quand même qui peut se
comprendre mais on va y arriver la
première raison c'est que la raison pour
finir c'était quoi je vous ai rappelé je
passe je le dis les terres qu'on a fait
à acheter à acheter il y avait un peu
plus hectares de terre on a eu on a plus
beaucoup de temps pour mettre la réforme
en place pour dire ce que ça première
raison c'est que les personnes qui
pouvaient pouvoir être installés ils
veulent pas le premier sous
il fallait avancer l'argent y compris la
taper lever elle-même pour une partie de
40% des parts et les porter jusqu'à son
épaule
voilà et peu de montage ça fait
voilà c'est ça un petit peu la
particularité de notre culture c'est pas
comment métropole ou quand quelqu'un
s'installe souvent il est financier il a
les moyens de mettre en oeuvre ça sa
volonté il y a eu ce problème
maintenant concernant la gestion la
Gironde dgfa alors j'ai oublié de le
dire le GFA congelés par la Chambre
d'Agriculture
là le problème
l'agriculture essentiellement quand on
voit
enfin chez nous en tout cas le poids du
vote que ça représente point élu c'est
pas négligeable de faire plaisir à
parce qu'on est sûr qu'on OK et c'est
vrai que le la dette de fermage n'a
cessé d'augmenter et à tel point à tel
point je l'ai dit je le redis le poids
de la SAFER dans ce système là on porte
des parts sociales en direct les parties
des 40% pour l'agriculteur on a un
portefeuille comme un peu un peu moins
de maintenant de 700000 euros 700000
euros on porte les 60% via lacéphale
c'est nous qui finançons et il se trouve
comme naturazi et les fromages n'ont pas
parce que aujourd'hui il est clair on
est en plein puisqu'on a un conseil à la
musculation la semaine dernière ou
ou la sefag dans sa feuille est
actionnée on avait une audite dgfa on a
une audit qui montre que aujourd'hui il
y a un laxisme criant de la Gironde DGF
le gérant qui est le président de
chambre c'est clair il a le problème
c'est que là aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
si on fait rien si on fait rien ça va
pas s'effondrer mais on pourra jamais
répondre à la tente aujourd'hui des
collectivités et de mettre le foncier à
ceux qui la travaille le foncier à ceux
qui vont pouvoir créer des véritables
exploitation pour pouvoir construire
leur avenir là on a ce problématique là
et là ça fait elle seule je pense pas
qu'elle pourra elle seule agir
concrètement il faut que les
collectivités il faut que l'État
certainement qui a aussi quand même un
droit de regard sur ce que une chambre
populaire peut faire ou ne pas faire et
il suffit simplement
et il suffit simplement qu'une volonté
politique alors il est vrai il est vrai
que si on ne fait rien ça on est
percussion
majeure de la saferou Guadeloupe alors
vous voyez c'est la triple peine
on a mis en place tout ça pas fait
on a dû porter des portes sociales pour
ceux qui ne pouvaient pas payer
maintenant il y a des impayés non pas
autour de
ces 8 millions
5 à peu près 8 millions oui c'est énorme
on a activé alors je dis puisque vous
allez avoir le scoop la on a eu un jeudi
dernier il y a eu des orientations ferme
pour pouvoir faire des choses on va
attirer la tronçonner de collectivités
pour demander d'agir parce
qu'aujourd'hui monsieur le sénateur faut
savoir que l'audit est sorti en juin
2022 on a lacéphale dont je suis membre
du Conseil veillant on a demandé à ce
que le gérant de la chambre puisse venir
nous expliquer les cartons il n'a jamais
honoré ce rendez-vous
voilà ça ça pose un problème
voilà voilà je veux pas du fait que
l'environnement le contexte est pas
facile mais le défi demain c'est quand
même qu'on puisse arriver à mettre le
foncier agricole pour ceux qui la
travaillent le crédit est à l'école qui
est majorité au sein de la Sépaq non
c'est la ferme c'est la saveur
il est il a il a 25 25 %. il est le
premier actionnaire c'est à faire le
deuxième le département et après le
Crédit Agricole vous voyez quand même
qu'on mesure
l'impact et la contribution de la saveur
de Guadeloupe imaginez-vous je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure 25% de la SAS
imaginez-vous qu'on a reconnu
tout tout était bétonnés élément
important c'est vrai que le sénateur dit
une chose qui mérite de soulever alors
pourquoi de notre PPAS on a envisagé
alors à l'époque les femmes Carnières
c'est des terrains exploitables
mécanisables plate
aujourd'hui on a un portefeuille
littéraire qui sont vallonnés qui ont
pas de possibilités d'exploitation à
moindre coût donc ça veut dire que
on a pris l'option et surtout les
évolutions législatives aujourd'hui là
ça fait la possibilité quand elle va à
l'époque elle est pas ça quand on vend
on met un cahier des charges pendant 15
ans il peut pas vendre à quiconque il
peut pas à faire n'est pas sollicité
pour faire l'acquisition il y a ça il y
a aussi le fait qu'il y a maintenant les
neuf on sait que on peut difficilement
envisager que celui de quelqu'un qui
travaille propriétaire à quelqu'un
maintenant il puisse faire les un
lotissement donc et aussi l'élément
important c'est l'étiquette qui sont à
faible valorité valorisation agronomique
et on aura du mal à les faire intégrer
un GFA on a du mal à les faire intégrer
un GFA c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
l'option de de de privilégier l'aspect
en pleine propriété et
d'agriculteurs formés et jeunes voilà un
petit peu pour expliquer et puis une
dernière chose pour expliquer aussi on a
alors dans le stock le sénateur lui elle
a dit on a une problématique
c'est que en dehors du Conservatoire
nous avons du stock de foncier qui est
classé distincts boisés n on avait à
l'époque une convention avec le Conseil
départemental pour pouvoir protéger ce
terrain donc faire l'acquisition et
protéger maintenant par rapport à la
situation
bon c'est un là ça fait le porte dans
son le support mais il est naturel il
est boisé mais le support pour la
relativité publique on va aller faire
comme ça mais ce n'est pas notre
vocation le vocation c'est le CD on a
bon espoir qu'un jour que bon les
départements voilà pourrait en faire
l'acquisition voilà voici rapidement je
passe
j'ai mis de répondre à des points
juste moi je voulais répondre je l'ai
oublié tout à l'heure mais
au sénateur Lurel les affaires en fait
elle régule la on va dire qu'il y a
une exception en termes de régulation
sur les prix
dans les territoires des dômes en
Guadeloupe ailleurs on est sur des prix
de fonciers qui sont globalement
qui correspondent à ce qu'on connaît
partout sur le territoire national que
ce soit la réunion ou la Martinique on
est sur des prix on n'est pas on est sur
des prix de quelques milliers d'euros
variations dont on va dire entre 5000 et
15000 euros en fonction de la qualité
des sols de l'emplacement de la
spéculation qu'on peut y faire les prix
que vous annoncez là sont des prix réels
je les conteste pas du tout ils sont
réels malheureusement mais ils sont très
spécifiques à une situation qui à un
moment donné
c'est dégradé là ça faire pouvait pas
forcément intervenir il y a quelques
années elle n'avait pas les moyens
financiers aujourd'hui c'est différent
Rodrigue trèfle l'a rappelé et puis sur
le le droit de prendre soin vous avez
posé la question sur l'enjeu en fait
vous avez qu'à regarder régulièrement
les représentants de la propriété privée
reprochent à la SAFER en tant que tel du
fait qu'elle est son droit de prévention
même si elle n'intervient pas que ça
régule le prix puisque on peut
intervenir
ce qui est pas complètement faux
ce qui est pas complètement faux et il
suffit de regarder le prix du foncier
agricole en France en comparaison de
prix agricoles du foncier en Europe et
vous allez vite voir que si on n'avait
pas d'efficacité on serait dans des prix
comparables on est à des prix inférieurs
ce qui donne aujourd'hui à la France un
véritable avantage compétitif pour son
agriculture si on n'avait pas si on
avait des prix comparables à 30000 40000
50 000 euros voire plus pour un certain
nombre de nos spéculations grande
culture on serait plus sur le marché
une question en même temps merci
Président je sais que
le prix
effectif du foncier bon on connaît les
sommets indiens avant il y avait une
liaison avec le prix de location
il y a encore en vigueur les textes sur
par exemple
les arrêtés préfectoraux que prennent
des préfets pour louer par exemple un
hectare de terre de bananes c'est un
volume ce sont les les prix liés au bon
ruraux pour la CAN c'est moins cher et
sur cette base là vous vendez à l'époque
un hectare de terre en banane ça
rapporte plus que la canne bon on était
à 150.000 euros c'était déjà beaucoup
aujourd'hui ça vaut une fortune et ça ne
sert plus à rien et j'ai bien
l'impression que au-delà du prix du
foncier lui-même le prix le loyer aussi
à exploser personne ne va louer un
hectare de terre agricoles à 5000 ou
6000 euros comme le disent le barème
électorale l'arrêter préfector il y a
donc une déconnexion
entre le marché agricole régulier et
administré par le préfet parce que tous
les prix sont libres sauf les cantines
scolaires maintenant c'est libre c'était
le prix le gaz et le carburant ça reste
administré et puis il y avait les
terrains agricoles on aujourd'hui ça ne
reste c'est libre totalement libre donc
les loyers
explosent et donc c'est pourquoi je pose
la question de l'utilité il faut
peut-être renforcer les moyens
législatifs d'un des terrains concrets
pour donner des moyens de régulation je
dirais pas d'administration ni de gel du
marché du foncier aussi petit style mais
de donner des moyens qu'on a pas à mon
sens aujourd'hui ou qui sont tombés en
des suites
je suis pas sûr que légalement ça soit
libre le problème c'est que les usages
fonctionnent mais comme le disait madame
la sénatrice jasmin tout à l'heure c'est
comme l'emploi de gens qui des
travailleurs illégaux c'est la pratique
mais c'est pas la légalité bon et là en
fait en l'occurrence je pense que c'est
ça il y a des gens qui ont des pratiques
illégales c'est l'usage mais c'est pas
légal
[Musique]
j'ai connu ces choses là on vous dit bon
écoute on me dit mais 15000 mais le
reste de sous table aujourd'hui la loi
Sapin vous pouvez plus rien payer
au-delà de 1000 € en liquide et il faut
prendre note 3 mois 4 mois 5 mois pour
aller à la banque de dire aujourd'hui
donnez-moi 2000 € 3000 euros pour avoir
20000 euros parce que la banque vous
demande c'est pourquoi on fait si votre
argent mais c'est pourquoi faire
aujourd'hui donc toute cette matière
pour réguler le marché il faut repenser
tout ça et voir comment faire pour être
efficace dans un petit pays où
les terrains agricoles sont rares
pardonnez-moi
mettons je donne la parole si tu peux
couper ton micro je suis avec toi ça
m'arrangerait c'est pas beaucoup la
parole mais simplement pour
l'enregistrement et j'ai laissé la
parole dernière question à Victoire
jasmin
voilà merci Monsieur la présidente ce
n'est pas pour trop prolonger mais on
n'a pas parlé d'irrigation en fait ça a
été évoqué mais on en a pas parlé alors
je voudrais parler d'une opération
innovante d'un jeune guadeloupéen qui a
mis en place une
logiciel en fait une possibilité
d'irriguer pour maîtriser l'eau déjà et
en fonction de l'hygrométrie moi je
trouve que c'est important de le
souligner dans un contexte où on a
beaucoup de problèmes d'eau et
particulièrement d'eau agricoles donc là
cette application permet à l'agriculteur
il fait que c'est programmé en fonction
de du taux d'humidité de pouvoir
déclencher ou pas automatiquement
l'irrigation donc c'est important de
voir cette innovation vient de jeûne le
jeune de chez nous et c'est important
dans le contexte actuel et alors je
voudrais demander à monsieur le
Président trèfle aussi alors il a parlé
de façon générale vous avez parlé
monsieur trèfle mais alors nous sommes
archipel il y a aussi les yeux du Sud et
particulièrement Malga Nantes alors
est-ce que tout ce que vous avez évoqué
concerne
Marie-Galante aussi et j'ai trouvé aussi
il y a des seins et puis je voudrais
savoir quels sont les relations que vous
avez en tant que ça fait avec les
domaines les services des domaines alors
est-ce qu'il y a des liens est-ce que
comment vous travaillez parce qu'on a
pas à l'effectivement du côté de la
valeur du foncier donc comment c'est
appréhender sur nos territoires de façon
générale en particulier merci beaucoup
très bien alors plusieurs questions
concernant les domaines c'est simple ils
sont ils sont la DIY du gouvernement
donc les services de l'État donc dans
les domaines ils sont ils font partie
pour Nantes de l'instant divisant de la
SAFER donc on travaille avec eux de
façon étroite ça c'est une première
chose concernant maintenant le
mygala c'est une très très bonne
question maintenant c'est un c'est une
dépendance de la Guadeloupe qui a
beaucoup de spécificité puisque
la majeure partie du foncier
agricole de mailloland appartient au
conseil départemental c'est c'est le
point de l'histoire parce qu'en fait il
y a eu les usines pareil là il y a pas
de griffon foncière mais c'est les
collectivités le département qui a
racheté les terres les faire valoir
direct de l'usine qui est toujours en
place et qui a connu beaucoup beaucoup
de déboires
là-dessus moi j'ai en train de faire
quelques inquiétudes pour ma galante
puisqu'on sait qu'il y a il y a qu'une
usine qui a eu cette difficulté ces
dernières années il y a
il y a une chute de la production gagnée
plus que quand Guadeloupe l'âge très
avancé les exploitants agricoles de
megaland on a aussi le fait que les
jeunes
qui vivent une double insularité les
jeunes ils quittent mais également il y
a la jolie Vesta récemment au président
du département il y a eu en urgence de
de réfléchir nous réfléchir comment
remettre en production littéraires qui
sont en friche d'autant plus qui est
nécessité pour alimenter la seule usine
qui est sur moi également
c'est quand même une situation un peu
compliqué mais comme je dis quand même
on a la chance il y a des heures
maintenant c'est à nous dirigeants et à
faire preuve d'intelligence pour voir
comment on pouvoir remettre tout ça en
activité en plus l'élément important à
souligner c'est que on a la chance il y
a pas de chloricon donc ce sont des
espaces quand même qui il y a pas de
Claude donc on est sûr que il y a pas il
y a pas de contamination au sol donc
c'est un grenier potentiel pour
alimenter
la production en Guadeloupe je fais le
tout alors celui qui a servi quoi les
gaz à l'école bon c'est le départ c'est
le département qui est en charge alors
il est vrai pour quelqu'un parler de les
impacts climatiques chez nous plus
qu'ailleurs on a quand même des
problèmes d'eau bon ça vous savez pour
le portable vous le savez mais problème
d'eau aussi agricole parce que il y a un
lien qu'on a pas fait et le lien il est
clair les canalisations qui amènent
l'eau qui prennent l'eau le Bastien
président
ce sont les canalisations d'eau
agricoles
et on a ces derniers ces dernières
années on a pour pouvoir répondre à
problématique de manque d'eau pour les
pour la population on a fonctionné en
faisant les usines de traitement sur le
agricole et ce qui fait qu'on a les
répercussions négatives puisqu'on arrive
plus à avoir de l'eau et pour
l'utilisation des cultures ça c'est un
véritable problème que vive
la population agricole d'une langue
interne on a souvent des coupures d'eau
qui sont de plus en plus
longues ça c'est véritable problématique
qui s'opposent
alors
le président le sénateur duquel a fait
allusion à la commune de petit canal
je vais faire un petit focus puisque on
a la chance en Guadeloupe très récemment
on a pu en ami en place la procédure de
15 inculte on a commencé les
investigations sur pratique tout petit
canal on a pu déceler ce petit canal
l'intégralité des sous-faces qui sont
pas cultivés ou bien suffisamment
cultivé on est en passe là très
prochainement de
le côté opérationnel puisque le côté
personnel c'est quoi c'est via le préfet
qui va écrire à tes propriétaires qu'on
a ciblé leur demander histoire de
remettre en production par eux-mêmes les
parcelles en friche ou soit de peau le
pouvoir installer un jeune ou un moins
jeune pour pouvoir mettre cette
production en friche voilà un peu les
aussi on va commencer par cette commune
là puisque le meilleur de la communauté
volontaire monsieur monsieur Blaise mon
a été volonté pour commencer parce qu'il
y a plus le président de la commission
agricole département pour commencer
cette opération sous son territoire en
tout cas on a on a bon espoir que en
matière de protection agricole du
foncier l'acteur que sont les affaires
en outre-mer on va continuer à faire les
choses même si comme le sénateur
il y a certaines difficultés mais qui
sont pas propres à la SAFER c'est propre
l'environnement qui colle même de la
Guadeloupe voilà merci je vais laisser
la parole à Vivette Lopez avant de
conclure cette audition oui juste deux
minutes je voulais dire à Monsieur
Catherine que nous il est prévu un
déplacement à Martinique du 16 au 20
avril donc si vous avez des
exploitations ou des personnes que nous
pourrions rencontrer qui pourrait nous
être de grande utilité je vous remercie
de nous les communiquer merci beaucoup
merci c'est le moment de conclure cette
audition on vous remercions évidemment
de la qualité de vos interventions et
puis des précisions qui nous ont été
apportées vous rappelons qu'un
questionnaire vous avez été adressé que
on est évidemment preneur des supports
de la des rapports d'activités nous vous
remercions concernant les trois domaines
en l'occurrence donc tous les toutes
communications que vous pensez utile
pour éclairer nos rapporteurs sur des
propositions notamment puisque c'est
bien aussi l'intérêt de travail qui est
mené rappelé à mes collègues que la
prochaine réunion sur ce thème du
foncier se passera le 23 mars qu'il va
falloir que nous recalions à un moment
pour nos amis de la Réunion qui n'ont
plus participer à cette réunion parce
qu'ils ont été pris par un déplacement à
l'étranger me semble-t-il donc on
essaiera de recaler parce que c'est
important qu'on puisse également avoir
leur regard bien évidemment donc on va
trouver une manière de pouvoir les
Yasser et puis vous dire que le 9 mars
prochain nous travaillerons sur la
continuité territoriale l'autre rapport
d'information et qu'on nous continuerons
nos travaux sur la parentalité en
outre-mer le 16 mars prochain voilà je
pense que d'ici là on a quand même un
programme qui est très chargé merci en
tout cas oui monsieur yes je sais pas
une pour vous préciser madame jasmin est
déjà a déjà participé tous les ans nous
avons une conférence de presse où on met
en avant avec les services de l'État le
prix des terres en France et bien
évidemment vous vous recevrez on invite
régulièrement les les élus avec qui on
était amenés à travailler dans l'année
en avant que de le faire publiquement on
est habité un petit déjeuner donc vous
allez vous recevrez tous une invitation
il y a un focus particulier sur la
problématique des dômes à l'occasion de
de ce petit déjeuner qu'on fait à
l'iPhone se faire donc en tout cas merci
encore de de votre invitation merci
monsieur le Président merci mesdames
messieurs bonne fin de journée